[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir bienvenue
à cette émission spéciale
coved 19 découverte en direct et ça ne
marie dussault en compagnie du grand
chantier un bon soir charge de la roma
bari bon soir nous vivons tous une
situation de remontent comme c'est
exceptionnel c'est du jamais vu
bien sûr on savait qu'une pandémie
allait frapper un jour quelque part on a
connu de grandes épidémies ces dernières
années mais on ne savait pas quand on
savait pas où ça commencerait alors la
grande question sommes nous prêts alors
l'association mondiale vous savez elle
est urgente c'est venu de chine c'est en
europe maintenant
mais face à la pandémie nous avons une
réponse pour vous ce soir tout
simplement la science la science qui
nous permettra de comprendre ce virus de
comprendre cette pandémie elle nous
permettra de l'affronter bien sûr
collectivement socialement de la vaincre
surtout et d'ailleurs on se demande
encore ce soir à tous
quand et comment on pourra s'en sortir
comme société bas la science va guider
les choix sociaux économiques et
politiques et la science dans notre
propre aux patientes sans merci anne
marie les équipes de découverte et de
24,60 donc unissent leurs efforts ce
soir pour cette émission spéciale
c'était munitions pour vous accompagner
dans cette nouvelle vie pour vous
informer pour faire le point sur l'état
de la science et surtout pour répondre à
vos quant à vos questions qu'on a en
compagnie de nos experts qui sont sur
notre plateau on les salue
il faut quand même vous préciser que
cette émission spéciale se poursuit
jusqu'à 20h sur i see télé en même temps
que ce mardi et jusqu'à 21h sur rdi et
charles parlant de questions et y en a
une qui a été soulevée hier en équipe
entre nous on ya réfléchi en a parlé
c'est celle de votre âge où
effectivement à marier j'ai 70 ans et
donc on sait que le premier ministre
legault a demandé à toutes les personnes
de plus de 70 ans de rester à la maison
et bien sûr je vais donner suite bien
sûr à cette demande du premier ministre
qui très important très raisonnable
logique et justifie dans des
circonstances mais pour le moment je
suis très heureux d'être ici s'est dit
d'errements avec l'équipe pour vous
présenter cette émission très importante
et après l'émission
je retourne chez moi est dorénavant ça
va être le télétravail pour moi et les
l'idée ou font un chant très rapidement
là dessus c'est de protéger les
personnes âgées depuis 70 ans parce que
si en a trop qui tombaient malades se
priverait les autres d'avoir accès au
système de santé ça fait partie des
raisons faudrait pas conscients tombé
malade convoquons en convenant que ces
services là alors la meilleure façon
d'empêcher ça c'est qu'on retourne à la
maison pour ne pas tomber malade mais
giteau verre de lait continue travail
alors faisons le point
parce que moment où on se parle il y à
plus de 160 2004 de kobe de 19 confirmés
dans le monde
on déploie maintenant jusqu'à 6500 morts
n'oublions pas quand même que 77 mille
personnes ont déjà été guerrier cas de
l'espoir pour les autres au canada
toutes les provinces sont maintenant
touchés pour un total de 321 cas au pays
on rapporte pour l'instant un seul décès
en colombie britannique
il ya un virus qui peut se propager plus
vite que le coronavirus c'est la
désinformation et c'est ce qui risque de
causer des dommages quand même
irréparable c'est pourquoi la santé
publique nationale canadienne et dans
toutes les provinces
lens quotidiennement des appels
aujourd'hui cet appel a été très senti
un grand appel à la responsabilité
collective et individuelle écoutant la
santé publique du canada et du québec
il faut être très clair aujourd'hui on
demande à chacun de prendre des mesures
importantes pour nous aider à retarder
la propagation de la couvée 19 et à
protéger le plus grand nombre de
personnes possible je vous dis fait ce
qu'on vous dit je vous en prie je vous
en supplie il va de votre propre santé
de la santé de nos concitoyens
puis on fait pas ça en disant hé ça me
tente d'avoir le trip de jouer à
dictature
non s'amuse pas ici on prend des
décisions extrêmement sérieuse pourquoi
parce que chacun d'entre nous peut faire
la différence cet appel est inspirée
sans doute des probabilités que ce virus
se propage à une vitesse fulgurante
et pour ça il ya un modèle le
scientifique qui permet de comprendre la
situation dans le monde les probabilités
comprendre les risques les scénarios
probables mais non pas des scénarios
certains il faut quand même en prendre
connaissance chaque site une
modélisation donc c'est théorique c'est
ce qui pourrait se produire si les
mesures actuellement en place n'était
pas là pensons à notre notre pays le
canada le canada regroupe 37,5 millions
de citoyens et on parle alors de 11 3
millions de malades qui pourraient être
atteints si on est dans le scénario de
30% autrement dit 30% de la population
canadienne qui pourraient être affectées
par ce nouveau virus
actuellement ils y ont été faits si rien
n'était fait des modèles actuellement
disques cd 30 à 70 pour ça mais nous
prenons l'hypothèse plus bas ce qui est
peut-être peut-être plus réaliste dans
des circonstances alors on estime qu
environ 10% d'entre eux des personnes
qui seront atteintes auront besoin de se
présenter dans un centre de soins et
cela signifie un million un million
d'hospitalisations est en fait environ
ça représente 5 % d'entre eux qui
devront être traitées aux soins
intensifs
on parle alors de cinquante six mille
deux cent cinquante personnes qui seront
acte qui devront aller dans les soins
intensifs donc on peut on peut
s'imaginer bien sûr que un nombre aussi
important ne pourra pas ne pourra pas
bénéficier de la totalité des souhaits
de service des soins de santé au canada
et depuis plusieurs jours déjà les gens
informés que s'informent sur les réseaux
d'information entendre parler d'une
courbe
la coupe c'est une belle illustration
des défis n'est ce pas et ça s'inspire
peut-être de cette mondialisation n'a
pas ce qu'il fout là faire mentir la
modélisation
c'est à dire qu'il faut arriver à une
situation où les efforts que l'on fait
en ce moment vont permettre de ralentir
les choses de permettre
à voir au fond peut-être un nombre
similaire de camille timonerie partie
sur une période plus longue et bien sûr
moins de cas possible alors on va
regarder cette courbe dans quelques
instants la voit ici on a un axe ici
horizontale c'est le temps de
propagation de l'épidémie depuis le tout
début jusqu'à une période plus éloignées
ici c'est le nombre de cas l'axé
vertical et l'on voit ici que la courbe
est très hautes et étroites
ça ressemble passablement ce qui s'est
passé en italie et en espagne où les cas
sont arrivés à toute vitesse et ont
complètement submergé les soins de santé
ici on voit une ligne qui est très
importante c'est le seuil de saturation
du système de santé ici on voit au fond
que cette courbe brutale dépasse le
seuil de saturation du système de santé
et à cause de ça bien on se rend compte
que beaucoup de personnes qui se
situerait dans ce groupe-là ci avait pas
les mesures de protection actuel et on
voit c'est en rouge maintenant que ces
personnes là ne pourraient pas
bénéficier des soins de santé mais qui
mériterait évidemment de pouvoir en
bénéficier
le but de tout ça de cette modélisation
voit ici les gens apparaître toutes ces
personnes si l'un qui sont de la même
couleur ou phoques la cloche ici rouge
eh bien ces personnes ne pourraient pas
bénéficier normalement des services de
santé ici on fond c'est ce qu'on veut
faire
on veut abaisser aplatir si je puis dire
cette courbe pour que non seulement elle
ne dépasse pas le seuil de saturation du
système de santé mais qu'en même temps
elle s'étale dans le temps
ça c'est très très très important ça
veut dire qu'on aurait quand même un
nombre de cas significatif mais qui
arriverait dans les hôpitaux de façon
progressive
espacées dans le temps et c'est ce qu'on
veut parce que c'est comme ça qu'on
pourrait justement s'occuper d'eux alors
ça c'est ce qui est visé par les mesures
actuelles qui sont si importantes
oui parce que les gens peuvent ne pas
les prendre au sérieux qu'on va aborder
cette question de ce soit comment
aplanir ou aplatir cette courbe gens
vont passer la soirée ensemble avec
l'usure et des questions du public et
donc sur le plateau
nos invités que je vous présente en
rafale docteur cécile rousseau pédo
psychiatre dr cissé tremblay
microbiologiques dr karl weiss également
un microbiologiste mais aussi président
de l'association
les microbiologistes et peut-être une
personnalité que vous connaissez
peut-être moins bien qui est la
conseillère scientifique en chef du
canada pourtant madame on a nos mères
alors vous êtes celle qui coordonnait
tous ces efforts scientifique vers les
choix importants qui doivent être faits
merci d'être avec nous et julie alors
vous êtes avec nous aussi ce soir pour
les questions bonsoir le pouls du public
à la maison les gens qui vont nous
écrire les téléspectateurs et voici
justement les moyens de le faire pour
nous poser vos questions mais aussi pour
réagir nous faire parvenir vos
commentaires
pouvez nous écrire sur twitter à la page
radio canada info également par courriel
à l'adresse habituelle 24-70 basse radio
canada.ca
et nous sommes aussi en diffusion
simultanée sur facebook live donc vous
pourrez commenter au bas de la diffusion
vidéo sur la page de radio-canada info
voici donc les moyens les façons de nous
contacter tout au long de cette émission
spéciale
alors merci je dis à tout à l'heure
alors charles a mis la table vous la
connaissez déjà cette modélisation ces
défis que cela pose
on a fait un état du monde et l'état de
la situation au canada un premier tour
de table avec vous sur sur la situation
actuelle
sa gravité sa sévérité ou les défis que
représente pour vous un anneau même pas
écouté c'est une situation qui est
certainement très sérieuse et puis il
faut vraiment faire le nécessaire pour
aplatir la courbe et c'est pas parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a on se sent pas
forcément menacé est en crise qu'il faut
être qu'il faut qu'il faut pas se
préoccuper de faire quelque chose et
certainement d'écouter les consignes de
santé publique mais on entendu ce cri
tout à l'heure est ce qu'on en fait trop
ou est ce qu'ils vont en faire plus que
moins à ce que c'est un principe de
précaution pour vous intéresse moi je
pense qu'on fait les bonnes mesures
certainement au québec on a pris des
mesures un peu exceptionnel le québec de
gens
duy n'est pas le québec deering semaine
et si on veut mettre tout en oeuvre pour
limiter la propagation du virus
c'est de minimiser les contacts entre
les gens donc les mesures qui ont été
mises en place on a pas de vaccin on n'a
pas de médicaments
pour l'instant la seule chose qui nous
reste c'est la quarantaine dans sa forme
très large mais qu'est ce qu'on dit
d'attendre et aux gens qui devant ces
chiffres et 10 rebonds c'est les médias
qui nous font peur c'est l'hystérie
après tout il y ait autant de calcium on
voit les chiffres qui augmentent de
manière exponentielle avec ce modèle là
et qui dit bord on a encore vu des gens
partir hier au mexique en danger mais
jusque là j'ai tout à fait je pense que
les gens nous disent depuis deux
semaines trois semaines nous demande
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour se
protéger si c'est le réflexe premier
alors là c'est le temps l'heure c'est un
m
un moment où de solidarité sociale où
les gens ont un rôle concret à jouer ce
rôle-là prend plusieurs formes respecter
les consignes d'hygiène mais surtout
parler à leurs proches qui justement
revient de voyage qui ne sont pas
nécessairement la pression et puis non
parce qu'ils sont encore dans leur mode
cool de voyages puis on pas
nécessairement été rejoint par cette
information là où il était mais c'est à
chaque citoyen de parler à leur famille
à leurs amis leur expliquer la situation
puis de leur demander s'ils veulent
protéger leurs êtres chers alors c'est
important de prendre les mesures qu'on
leur demande de prendre parce qu'une
espèce de sentiment qui contredit par ce
que je vais vous poser dans un instant
la dame a reçu comme question bien
sentiments ne nous rapporte pas de
jargon donc un peu en vacances et ben
maintenant il ya beaucoup d'angoissé à
côté de gens qui se demandent où tracer
la ligne que ce que je fais que ce que
je fais pas on respecte les conseils de
la direction de la santé publique ont
fait notre quarantaine quand on revient
de voyage qu'on considère ça comme des
valets christ et je disais tu étais qu
on considère ça comme des vacances des
vacances des fois quand organes vacances
du monde j'aurais besoin de vacances de
mes vacances parce que j'ai trop fait et
c'est le temps d'en profiter
et puis en même temps de penser à nos
aînés en même temps l'envers de cette
médaille docteur rousseau puis on le
voit bien par les centaines de questions
que nous avons reçue c'est une angoisse
jeu et se séparent spécialité comme ce
qu il yad abord vous êtes une grande
experts des enfants victimes de la
guerre
r des gens qui m'aident et adultes tous
ceux qui vivent des traumatismes
terrible en quoi ce que l'on vit
maintenant et quelque chose d'angoissant
est un traumatisme et à quel niveau
alors je dirais que l'epr pour les
humains comme pour tous les mammifères
sont très utiles la peur c'est ce qui
nous permet de rester en vie par rapport
à une menace ou on ignore encore
beaucoup de choses comme celle de la
pandémie actuellement il ya trois
possibilités je pense qu'on les voit
autour de nous une possibilité c'est
finalement l'appel de docteur arruda
c'est de dire j'ai peur je me renseigne
et je me protège
1 je prends acte et collectivement mais
il ya deux autres possibilités elles
sont aussi beaucoup la fcd aussi des
façons d'échapper à cette peur là et est
la première c'est de dire même pas peur
et ça c'est une défense contre la peur
donc les gens qui disent ça n'est pas
grave ça ne touchera pas on est dans
l'ordre de la pensée magique et c'est
aussi une défense contre la peur dont
vous voyez si on rassure les gens
peut-être que ceux qui disent même pas
peur ils vont faire un peu plus
attention surtout s'ils se sentent
responsables et l'autre extrême c'est
finalement quand la peur est là on a
certainement des cas en ce moment nous
paralyse et ça c'est inutile donc la
peur qui devrait nous protège et devient
en elle-même un problème et nous
paralyse tellement et au niveau social
qu'on ne peut plus bouger
donc comment est-ce qu'on peut utiliser
une crainte légitime du virus pour se
protéger sans être paralysée et sans
jouer a même pas peur sans jouer à
chicken parce que ça c'est dangereux
oui parce qu'on l'a vu la réaction dans
les épiceries d'un magasin et les
étagères sont vides au niveau des études
scientifiques qui peuvent exister charge
d'en connaître certaines demandé est ce
qu'on doit tenir compte comme décideur
de l'impact social du genre de décisions
que l'on prend oui la santé avant
l'économie
on veut sauver des vies mais comment on
fait ça pour mesurer l'impact social de
ce genre de diffusion
bah écoutez c'est sûr que la science est
très important puis d'ailleurs la
science
ce psycho social est très importante
aussi les sciences économiques sont
importantes et c'est toujours une
balance dans une crise c'est une
dynamique donc ce qui était plus
approprié au début et le deuxième - en
cours de route et donc il faut être prêt
à réagir et rajuster le tir mais charme
mais je pense aussi aux enfants madame
n'est ce pas les enfants vont très
bousculés en ce moment ceux qui sont en
service de garde vont probablement
changer de personnes qui s'occupent
d'eux pour les jeunes enfants qu'est ce
que ça peut vouloir dire ça alors je
pense qu'il faut distinguer pour les
enfants de stress important d'abord la
peur de leurs parents la peur des gens
autour d'eux donc la peur de la pandémie
et le bouleversement de la routine qui
est créée par cette forme de quarantaine
collective avec l'arrêt des écoles et
des cpe
1 ce qui s'applique à fond là comme
principe c'est ce qu'on appelle l'aide
de premiers de premier niveau au niveau
psychologique donc pour les enfants une
fois il va falloir rétablir une routine
rétablir un sentiment de normalité et
expliquer avec des mots qui leur
convienne qui conviennent à leur âge
sont pourra reparler donc on parle pas
un enfant de trois ans comment par
l'enfant de sept ans comme en parle un
enfant de 15 ans donc avoir les bons
mots pour leur expliquer ce qui se passe
pour qu'ils adoptent des comportements
sécuritaires mais sans être tétanisé
parce que sinon on se retrouve avec plus
de problèmes et pour les enfants un
petit peu plus vieux les enfants et
pré-adolescents les adolescents on ne
sait pas combien de temps tout cela va
durer
qu'est ce qu'on leur dit alors au niveau
des préadolescents et des adolescents
quelque chose qui est extrêmement
important c'est de faire appel plus au
sens de responsabilité sociale et à leur
pouvoir d'agir qu'à une règle
les pré ados et les ados déteste les
règles ou si quelques fois mais a fait
au début mai les prix ados et les ados
c'est vraiment un moment de révolte et
donc imposer quelque chose on court le
risque à part si on a des ados anxieux
de transgression donc je vais faire
exactement le contraire parce que voilà
c
menaçant de m'affirmer et ça c'est
dangereux alors que si on dit aux
adolescents écoutez et aux jeunes
et ce qui est vrai d'ailleurs donc on ne
ment pas on a vraiment besoin d'eux et
en ce moment on a besoin d'eux on a
besoin de vous pour protéger pour
protéger vos grands parents pour
protéger le vieux monsieur au coin de la
rue pour protéger ces gens plus
vulnérables que vous voyez que vous
connaissez je pense qu'à ce moment là on
transmet un sentiment de responsabilité
et on leur donne un pouvoir d'agir
je pense qu'il faut aller de ce côté là
très positif alors tu repousses alors
quelques questions une question d' andré
roy
on va vous montrer à l'écran si on
réussit à tati sur la courbure est il
autant de personnes affectées au total
on diminue la quantité de personnes
affectées en même temps mais qu'est ce
qui fait que l'épidémie
l'épidémie se prolonge est ce que ça
veut dire la courbe c'est qu'on pourrait
avoir potentiellement le même nombre de
cas total si vous voulez mais dispersés
sur une beaucoup plus grande période de
temps donc ça permettrait d'amenuiser
l'impact en un moment mais plutôt de
l'état les piles autre chose c'est que
moins on attaque à mon a potentiellement
de cas secondaires donc ça peut aussi
nous faire gagner du temps jusqu'aux
moment d'amener avec potentiellement un
vaccin ou quelque chose d'autre qui
amenuiserait encore la courbe
donc l'idée c'est d'essayer d'avoir le
moins de cas possibles sur la plus
longue période de temps possible en tout
cas décidé d'écraser pour ne pas inonder
le système de santé est actuellement si
je peux me permettre dans notre système
de santé dans nos hôpitaux et en
particulier dans les soins intensifs
est-ce que c'est déjà complet ou est ce
que il ya encore de l'argent c'est pas
complet heureusement mais on commence à
avoir des cas au québec de gens qui sont
très malades
ce qu'il faut aussi de voir si wes qu'on
est ce cette journée si combien de cas
on avait au québec qui a une semaine
et combien de cas on avait au québec il
ya deux semaines et même si ça peut
paraître pas beaucoup pour des gens qui
dirait mais voyons c'est rien du tout on
dit 35 ha on a une population de loups
million et demi il faut voir la
progression de la maladie
on est ce pas tout le monde ont pu
capter des gens symptomatique qui sont
pas un peu trop malades des gens qui eux
mêmes vont pas chercher à se faire
tester parce qu'ils sont soit un petit
peu grippée puis je dis bon c'est pas
grave ça va passer et c'est donc on n'a
peut-être pas l'idée
exact du nombre de cas mais ce qui est
important c'est l'accélération de la
courbe des ces cas là et on l'a vu dans
d'autres pays
alors pierre lachance justement enchaîna
sur l'histoire de cette courbe nous dit
nous devrions nous pas laisser le virus
se propage et naturellement pour
stimuler le système immunitaire des
humains contre un virus qu'on devra
affronter dans les années à venir
donc il ya même quelqu'un qui ajoute
compte tenu du taux de mortalité entre 1
et 4% les mesures prises sont exagérées
donc quelqu'un qui dit pourquoi ce qu'on
laisse parler les choses quelqu'un qui
dit seulement ces missions sont
exagérées d'attendre et bien en fait
faut être très très prudent si on dira
si on disait de laisser aller les choses
parce que c'est quand même un pathogène
qui est très morbide qui est mortelle
beaucoup plus que la grippe saisonnière
et qui risque d'affecter des populations
plus vulnérables de façon beaucoup plus
grave que la population générale quand
on parle d'un taux de mortalité de 14%
chez les gens de 80 ans et plus c'est
pas banal ça ça veut dire que si ça
rentre dans un foyer de personnes âgées
tout le foyer parce qu'on a un tableau
qui illustre le groupe bien dommage
alors on peut se permettre comme société
un risque si grand
du moins regardé les poussins elle a
envoyé le cycle risque de mortalité
augmente directement proportionnellement
avec l'âge
puis à partir de 65 ans et plus ça
devient très significatif alors on ne
voudrait pas laisser un virus comme ceux
se propager dans une communauté qui n'a
justement pas d'imiter on sait qu
éventuellement il pourrait y avoir une
deuxième vague par ce genre de virus l'a
peut-être qu'il va partir tout seul de
sa belle-maman quelques mois puis qu'on
veut en être débarrassé peut-être que
non peut-être qu'il va avoir une
deuxième bague à ce moment là il y aura
des gens immunise
et puis ça probablement que ça aidera la
situation charles va nous présenter un
reportage dans quelques secondes mais
avant je vais m'accrocher une nouvelle
qui est sorti en fin d'après midi
d'après midi par un collègue de t'avoir
sur le papier web vous pouvez aller le
dire
la médecin en chef d'ottawa semble dire
qu'il y aurait quelques centaines de
codes déjà de transmission dans la
communauté
peut-être au-delà de 1000 qu'est ce que
ce que vous connaissez la situation à ce
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça parce
qu'on a toujours dit depuis le début ça
va bien il n'y a pas de transmission
dans la communauté melon à tahoua on est
en ontario ben écoute et on le saura
quand on doit avoir quand on va se
mettre à tester tout le monde n'est ce
pas ou d'un échantillon de personnes qui
ne sont pas finalement à qui n'ont pas
les symptômes mais par rapport à
d'autres pays ce qu'on sait par exemple
c'est qu'il est probable que pour chacun
détecté il y aurait jusqu'à 10 fois
un des cas qui sont pas détectés encore
dans la communauté a détecté on va
parler du dépistage c'est ce qui nous
amène à poser la question au dr weiss
par exemple si on est asymptomatique
est ce qu'on est contagieux alors je
vous aurais dit c'est ça la beauté de la
science c'est qu'il ya jusqu'à il n'y a
pas si longtemps non mais il ya des
données qui disent que peut-être que oui
qu'il ya des gens symptomatique qui
transmettrait le virus
donc il faut falloir et combien il
transmettrait le virus est ce qu'il
transmettrait mieux que des gens très
symptomatique combien de jours avant
d'être symptomatique
il ya encore beaucoup d'incertitudes
l'idée derrière tout ça c'est que
finalement on en apprend beaucoup avec
ce virus et il ya des choses qui vont
changer
au mois de décembre 2010 neuf personnes
connaissaient le kovy 19
d'un autre côté on peut de temps on a
identifié le virus ont la séquence et on
sait quels types de virus et on a appris
beaucoup mais on ne connaît encore pas
tout on a aussi fait des analogies avec
l'influenza et comme disait ma collègue
dr tremblay il ya des choses qu'on
partage avec l'influenza mais aussi des
choses qui sont différentes mais qu'on
sait pas aller l'inflammation par
exemple ça c'est un problème le spa oui
tout à fait alors ça vous avez un
reportage à nous présenter
oui justement parlons de l'information
on va
on va parler du virus lui même on va
parler on va rappeler comment tout ça
c'est à progresser et puis on va
regarder plus en détail au fond quels
sont les efforts qui se fond pour
essayer de juguler tout ça j'aurais des
questions du public a pas encore
regardons pour commencer covin 19 ans
coronavirus les eas aux maladies du
coronavirus il y a près de deux mois
le monde découvrait cette nouvelle
maladie apparue en chine en quelques
semaines à peine cette infection
respiratoire a touché plus de cent mille
personnes et fait plusieurs milliers de
morts
sa propagation a provoqué des mesures
exceptionnelles des millions de gens ont
été confinés et ressortissants étrangers
rapatriés d'urgence puis mis en
quarantaine d'événements rassembleurs
annulé
c'est du jamais vu dans le milieu
scientifique aussi le virus a suscité
une mobilisation sans précédent
les chercheurs du monde entier se sont
attelés à la tâche de comprendre et
contrer le plus vite possible
cette nouvelle menace avec une rapidité
inédite
ils ont échangé ouvertement leurs
analyses et leurs réflexions sur divers
sites internet et dans les médias
sociaux
plusieurs grandes revues scientifiques
ont accéléré la publication des travaux
sur ce nouveau virus en quelques
semaines des dizaines d'articles sur le
sujet avait déjà par lé retour en
arrière le 7 janvier
des chercheurs chinois ont identifié un
chez des patients atteints de pneumonie
à coronavirus jusqu'ici inconnu à peine
trois jours plus tard et publié sa
séquence génétique
grâce à cette information de nombreux
laboratoires ont pu rapidement mettre au
point des tests diagnostiques pour
détecter l'infection
depuis des dizaines d'autres
échantillons du virus ont été récoltés
sur des malades et leurs génomes ont été
décryptés en un temps record ces données
ont permis aux experts de les comparer
pour reconstituer en quelque sorte
l'arbre généalogique du pathogène il
montre que le nouveau coronavirus est un
proche cousin du strass un autre
coronavirus qui avaient tué près de 800
personnes en 2003 mais ses plus proches
parents se trouvent chez les
chauves-souris une piste pour les
chercheurs qui veulent identifier le ou
les animaux doués prévenu le virus
le moment de cette transmission de
l'animal à l'humain intéresse aussi les
scientifiques
là aussi la génétique les a aidé les
génomes analysés sont tous très
semblables le virus aurait donc
relativement peu évolué depuis qu'il se
propage dans la population humaine
ces faibles variations suggèrent qu'ils
ne circule depuis la mi novembre environ
si on considère qu'une premiers patients
recensés est tombé malade début décembre
cela signifie que cette nouvelle maladie
a été détectée rapidement et pas assez
pour empêcher sa propagation
deux aspects du virus sont
particulièrement cruciaux sa
contagiosité
combien de personnes un malade infecté
et sa létalité combien risque d'en
mourir
les chiffres sont encore incertains mais
en moyenne un patient atteint du corps
d'un virus pourrait affecter un peu plus
de deux personnes
son taux de mortalité lui se situerait
entre 1 et 3%
comparons le à d'autres virus
respiratoires
d'abord son cousin le virus du strass il
est à peu près aussi contagieux mais
plus virulents il a tué un malade sur
dix avant d'être enrayée en 2003 la
rougeole elle
plus contagieuse mais tue moins de 1%
des gens qu'elle infecte la jeep arrière
plus contagieuse très mortels quant à la
grippe saisonnière elle est un peu moins
contagieuse que le nouveau virus et u11
banane sur mille environ
c'est relativement peu mais il faut se
rappeler que le virus de l'influenza
affecte chaque année des millions
personnes au canada il en tue 3500
paradis si le coronavirus suscitant
d'inquiétude c'est surtout à cause de sa
nouveauté
a priori personne n'est immunisé contre
lui il pourrait donc faire beaucoup de
victimes ne plus il n'existe pour le
moment ni traitement ni vaccin pour le
contrer les scientifiques qui
travaillent mais cela prendra des mois
d'ici là notre seule arme c'est de
circonscrire d'épidémies et de traiter
au mieux des malades on le fera d'autant
mieux que progressera notre connaissance
de l'inpi
hyper connectés virus voyage de plus en
plus vite
heureusement la science accélère elle
aussi la science accélère madame le
maire ou est-ce qu'on allait rapidement
là dessus que maintenant on en est au
début mais quand même en l'espace de
trois mois on a fait énormément de
progrès et écouter le fait qu'on ait pu
avoir la séquence du virus là aussi
rapidement a permis d'avoir des tests
diagnostiques donc c'est c'est quand
même énorme mais on sait toujours pas
comment tu est qu'une fois que le virus
est dans notre corps comment est ce que
vraiment il l'a fait les ravages donc ça
c'est des choses encore à comprendre en
eau des questions la semaine première
question d'une personne qui ne s'est pas
identifié mais elle est intéressante la
question les enfants sont-ils touchés
par ce virus on a vu la faible
proportion tout à l'heure mais sont ils
considérés plus à risque comme les
personnes âgées madame troni a eu
beaucoup de choses qui ont été dites sur
les enfants et le lakovic 19
les enfants peuvent être infectés de la
même façon que les adultes ou les
personnes plus âgées par le virus
en général ils vont faire une forme de
maladie moins sévère en général il ya
des codes et des cris d'enfants qui ont
fait des maladies sévères que se sont
retrouvés aux soins intensifs donc faut
pas dire que chez les enfants de façon
uniforme ça your happy seront pas malade
mais ce n'est pas la même chose que la
grippe la grippe ordinaire ou petits
enfants sont très à risque et les
personnes âgées sont très à risque dans
le cas de la coved 19 la dangerosité
augmente avec l'âge donc les enfants
sont moins à risque de faire des
maladies sévères il faut les protéger
cambrai faut les protéger parce qu'ils
peuvent non seulement par une maladie
puis n'oubliez pas quand on parle de
maladie sévère
ce dont se méfie c'est d'aller aux soins
intensifs d'être obligé d'être
hospitalisé puis tout ça mais une
maladie modérée c'est quand même une
pneumonie
c'est les gens ne sont pas vraiment bien
je voudrais pas que nos enfants se
retrouvent malades non plus mais aussi
ce qu'ils peuvent propager la maladie
auprès de leurs familles de leurs aînés
de leurs grands parents
surtout qu'il ya qu'il n'y a pas de
traitement
mélanie monogrenade peu plus tard pour
mieux comprendre mais pas comment
un concept des monnaies ne peut pas être
soulagé ou guéris comme d'autres mais
chars vous avez une question ou une
autre question celle ci d'une marque
albert bélanger est ce que l'épidémie du
coronavirus faiblira lorsque les gens
deviendront immunisés avec le temps ça
va être un ensemble de facteurs je vous
dirais alors bien sûr les gens qui vont
faire l'infection vont être probablement
fort probablement protéger ils ont
développé des anticorps ils vont devenir
un peu un cul de sac pour le virus c'est
à dire que le virus ne pourra plus
utiliser ces gens là pour en affecter
d'autres donc oui mais il ya aussi un
ensemble de facteurs où on va essayer
d'atténuer l'impact du virus donc ce
qu'on est en train de faire actuellement
vous savez on avait dit que ce virus là
a une capacité de transmission quand
vous l'avez mentionné d'à peu près à ce
qu'on appelle un air 022 c'est à dire
grosso modo qui s'est pas encore très
clair que chaque cave a généré deux
autres cas à partir du moment où vous
êtes capable de générer moins d'un cas
pour un nouveau cas c'est là vous avez
commencé à casser la chaîne de
transmission du virus
donc c'est un ensemble de facteurs qui
vont faire que le virus va s'atténuer
avec le temps
la seule chose qu'on sait pas c'est
qu'est ce qui va se passer en afrique
est ce qui va se passer dans les
systèmes de santé qui n'ont pas des
moyens considérables pour pouvoir lutter
contre ce virus dans le cadre du strass
qui a frappé une région 2003 je pense
ont développé un vaccin et c'est quand
on l'a voulu le tester bas l'épidémie
s'était épuisée est ce que si le
phénomène que vous décrivez qui s'est
passé ça peut être ça mais ça peut être
aussi d'autres facteurs vous savez aussi
les virus ont une espèce d'équilibré
c'est à dire le sras c'est un virus
beaucoup plus virulents entre guillemets
que ce virus là vous avez vu vous l'avez
montré que le taux de mortalité était
beaucoup plus élevé mais quand un virus
devient et vous l'avez montré encore
mieux avec le h5n1 le virus de la grippe
aviaire plus un virus devient entre
guillemets virulent plus la difficulté
des fois se transmettre parce que les
virus faut pas oublier à l'autre extrême
un simple rhume stas transmet très
facilement mais c'est très peu virulent
donc un équilibre qui va se faire
quelque part entre la virulence du virus
sa transmissibilité
pourquoi le sera ça a été si a été
bloqué on l'a bloqué parce que
probablement que sa transmission n'était
pas si extraordinaire que ça il en a vu
à toronto initialement c'est mal parti
mais après ça ça c'est comme un petit
peu les mesures ont été prises puis ça a
disparu mais en même temps
on savait qu'il y aurait une pandémie un
moment donné mais que le maire sticker
est tout ce que vous pouvez numérique et
que moi et que l'on a vu à travers le
pays des endroits où les budgets ont été
coupés mais est ce qu'on savait que ça
allait frapper avec cette ampleur un
moment ou un autre les ondes oui on le
savait on sait que depuis surtout
l'influenza que même avant h1n1 les
gouvernements ont tous préparé des plans
de préparation contre une pandémie
d'influenza mais c'est aussi bon pour
des pandémies de d'autres virus
donc les gens le savent mais ce qui
arrive c'est que quand on oppose souvent
quand ça arrive à chaque dix ans c'est
plus les mêmes personnes qui sont en
place des gens oublient et puis photo
faut raviver les protocoles qui avait
déjà été pensé puis tout ça mais la
théorie et les leurs elle existe comment
se préparer pour ça il faut la remettre
en place je pense que madame peut être
plus est de convaincre les gouvernements
d'investir des millions à aix et je
crois que l'exemple par exemple du
strass est intéressant parce qu'on s'est
mobilisé on a commencé à développer des
vaccins puis on a arrêté de fait et on a
aussi arrêté de développer des
antiviraux de façon soutenue alors je
crois que c'est très important de
continuer les efforts parce que ça va on
va avoir faire face continuellement je
crois à des infections virales et en ce
moment on n'a pas vraiment d'outils
appropriés pour pour les pour lui qu'on
contrôle à vous de dire au gouvernement
à à les imiter de l'avant il ya ça c'est
surtout de rester de façon à soutenir
claude gascon à une question quand le dr
weiss affirme que la personne qui déride
de lakovic 19 est immunisée cela peut-il
également pour les personnes âgées
bref si à 85 j'attrape la coved 19
est ce à dire que ça en effet deux mois
à les y est allé sur hp ensuite charles
si vous l'avez attraper que vous êtes
guéri vous êtes guéri pour al ahly ne
l'est pas la seule source dans la
médiation sera pas une chose mais ce qui
est une source d'angoissé qu'on a vu
qu'on m'a dit de faire trembler que plus
vous êtes âgés puis vous avez un risque
donc je comprends qu'à 80 ans vote
risque de complications est plus élevé
mais ça veut pas dire qu'il faut quand
même encourager les gens à leur dire que
la majorité des gens à date qui ont plus
de 80 ans vont aussi passer au travers
alors je pense qu'il ya cet aspect là
c'est un risque relatif et ils étaient
les questions non mais on continuera
dans la même veine jean aux questions
après inversons la statistique
20 15 % de chances d'en décéder c'est
terrible mais 85 % de chances de s'en
sortir c'est quand même pas mal et je
pense que pour répondre à la question de
madame il faut faire il faut faire
confiance parce que la façon dont on se
sent influences comme vous savez notre
immunité et donc oui tout à fait on le
sait quand on est déprimé quand on est
stressé notre immunité diminue moi je
dis dono protégeons-nous mais donnons la
chance au coureur pensons que même si ça
nous arrive
pour mettre toutes les chances de notre
côté il ya toujours de l'espoir
oui on sait très bien dit je pense
l'importance la maison et on vient de
nous apprendre que l'alberta vient
d'annoncer qu'elle ferme ces écoles
primaires et secondaires ainsi que que
les garderies
alors maintenant julie vous avez des
questions oui certainement je voudrais à
marie et charles depuis le début de
l'émission
plus d'un millier de questions nous ont
été envoyées de la part du public
on voit vraiment que ça soulève toutes
sortes d'interrogations d'inquiétude
aussi je vous rappelle donc d'abord les
moyens de nous contacter pour vos
commentaires vos réactions et bien sûr
vos nombreuses questions pouvaient le
faire sur twitter à l'aide du conte
radio-canada info par courriel à
l'adresse 24 tirs et 60 euros basse
radio canada.ca et sur facebook
sur la diffusion facebook live
directement sur la page de radio canada
info je vous lance donc trois questions
très science très recherche pour
commencer jean pellerin de montréal qui
nous écrit dans le corps d'un individu
contaminés par la coved 19
est ce que la maladie a une signature au
genre d'adé m duthil qui permettrait de
savoir scientifiquement parlant qui l'a
contaminée dans son entourage
je vous présente mes deux autres
questions et je voulais ramène par la
suite il ya tania gauthier qui nous
écrit sur facebook en nous demandant si
on peut expliquer en fait la naissance
du coronavirus en soit les cellules de
la maladie est un peu son parcours
global on sait à l'échelle d'un point de
vue géographique mais davantage d'un
point de vue humain et demande-t-elle et
enfin on à pierre lachance qui nous
écrit pour nous demander at on observé
des mutations du virus depuis les
premiers cas d'infection
je vous laisse donc sur cette troisième
question et on reviendra aux autres
offert un doublé les bleus mais la
première et à la troisième question en
même temps parce que la personne
demandait si une signature du virus donc
ce sont des virus à arn et donc pas de
virus à adn donc c'est comme ça qu'on
détecte le virus dans le corps d'une
personne c'est qu'on identifie la
séquence d'aériennes qui est dans dans
l'individu qui est infecté maintenant
dans dans les virus qui mute beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup c'est
relativement facile de comparer deux
séquences d'individus différents et de
voir si elles sont reliées entre elles
parce que la séquence ginseng va être
très différentes mais dans des virus
comme le coréen au virus qui n'est pas
un virus qui mute beaucoup il mute comme
tous les virus mais pas une vitesse
incroyable pour autant chez lui et
papotant celui comme le vih ou
l'hépatite c c des virus qui mute
énormément alors pour faire des liens
identifier précisément si le virus den-1
est exactement le même très différente
de l'autre on ne pourrait pas le dire à
l'instant une autre question celle de la
deuxième le par le global où elle est
célèbre par tête je peux continuer sur
la question des cellules alors le virus
quand il entre dans le corps humain
dit que c'était par voie respiratoire
essentiellement il va se loger dans des
cellules en général qui tapissent notre
système respiratoire et il y a un petit
récepteur à la surface de certaines de
ces cellules c'est comme une clé avec
une serrure qui permet au virus de sa
tâche et ça ça donne que c'est un
récepteur qui est utilisé par notre
organisme pour beaucoup d'autres choses
entre autres pour contrôler
l'hypertension artérielle qui est
exprimé dans le code du diabète ecce
terra
donc c'est pour ça qu'on pense qu'il
peut y avoir des liens avec ses co
morbidités l'honneur en effet il ya une
question qui est soulevée par ce que
vous avez dit tout à l'heure le fameux
dépistage charles vous avez examiner ces
questions à travers le monde on a des
des politiques différentes le ms suggère
d'être agressif dans le dépistage
on a pris peut-être de retard et six au
canada je ne sais trop
mais on a il ya des endroits maintenant
où on dépiste plus et on a les résultats
plus rapidement voit ce qu'on en est ici
de ce bout de terrain c'est certainement
pourquoi je crois des pistes et pourquoi
les dépister pour coincer les voyageurs
c'est pas nous d'abord il faut
comprendre que 37 arriver on n'avait pas
de test de dépistage commerciaux que
l'on pouvait commencer du jour au
lendemain alors il a fallu que on y
entre on fabrique des tests maison
laboratoire national à winnipeg puis
c'est toute une chaîne donc le
laboratoire national et à winnipeg
ensuite il transmet cette information
aux laboratoires provinciaux comme notre
laboratoire de santé publique au québec
qui lui a c'est à son tour de faire les
tests de valider des tests peut-être
changer modifier des affaires et de
trouver un test où on sait on est sûr
qu'il va fonctionner parce qu'il faut
aussi s'assurer que le test en question
qu'une fois qu'on va le faire à
quelqu'un et on vous dit vous êtes
négative que vous êtes une vraie
négative et que si vous êtes positive
vous êtes aussi une vraie positive et
que ça ne croise pas avec d'autres fait
ce cadeau de virus des coronavirus alors
il ya tout cet aspect là donc il ya eu
après ça il ya un aspect aussi de
capacité de faire des tests dont il faut
encore une fois au mois de décembre 2019
on connaissait pas le coronavirus
aujourd'hui on le connaît donc il faut
montrer une capacité en puissance de
fabriquer des tests et là on va
commencer à voir des tests commerciaux
et donc ça va être une question de temps
avant que la capacité de faire des
grosses quantités de test va être là au
québec ont annoncé qu'en parfait de
quelques centaines par jour à steam
400 et mais la question est ce que nous
on aura des tests pour lesquels on aura
les résultats en quelques heures
par contre de droit jouer en ce moment
le test qui est fait c'est un test qui
détecte justement le matériel génétique
de vie du virus
et c'est pour ça que je voulais trappier
de votre soeur ou de votre frère c'est
la même séquence que vous allez voir
donc on savait pas d'où vient le virus
est ce que ça dit aussi c'est qu'il faut
que le virus soit déjà en vous qu'il y
ait assez de particules virales
impression de concentration pour pouvoir
le détecter
vous avez tout compris mais elles sont
le pas de symptômes mais mais mais mais
le résultat on l'a emmené en deux heures
l'as et c'est assez rapide
le problème c'est qu'avant on avait pas
mais l'autre choix au canada on ne le
sait pas ce que le test brun 2 à 3
heures à réaliser mais sauf que
l'échantillon parts de l'endroit où le
collecter se rendre au laboratoire qui
le fasse qui ne fait etc
c'est pour ça au québec on a des
résultats dans 24 heures tant mieux mais
peut-être l'autre chose aussi à
mentionner c'est qu'en ce moment on peut
détecter qui infecte et on sait pas qui
a été infecté et donc qui s'en est remis
alors les chiffres que nous avons
peut-être sous-estiment le nombre de
personnes qui l'ont eu
mais qui de fait ont vaincu le virus et
sont en pleine forme et ça on va le
savoir le jour où on va avoir un test de
sang qui détecte les anticorps justement
qu'on a fait contre le virus puisse est
en train d'être d'être fait vous les
spécialistes charge vous intéressez vous
à découvrir affiche opérateurs mais il
ya beaucoup d'espoir mis dans la
recherche
pourtant veut un traitement on veut un
vaccin poulet en a que dans l'esprit des
gens c'est encore demain matin la
semaine prochaine aucun alors qu'est ce
qui se passe si vous l'avez fait avec
gaël
oui je te vois découverte la semaine
dernière travailler très fort en
rencontrant du chercheur de plusieurs
laboratoires pour justement essayer de
déterminer qu'est ce qui se passe
exactement c'est justement notre
collègue ici gaël lucia berdou
journaliste qui a fait ce travail avec
que le réalisateur jean françois michaud
sont alliés dans plusieurs laboratoires
alors c'était quoi votre démarche
écoutez on l'est vous l'avez évoqué tout
à l'heure le la pandémie de kobe 19 et
inédite est la science qui s'est faite
autour d'elle est aussi née du cha donc
dans les laboratoires ça se voit depuis
le début de l'épidémie la quantité
d'informations qu'on a acquise est
phénoménal malheureusement on a encore
énormément de questions donc celle à
laquelle on s'est intéressé c'est celle
que beaucoup de gens se posent des
vaccins et des traitements qu'on peut
peut-on les espérer et peut- on les
espérait rapidement pour contrer cette
pandémie donc nous on a voulu rencontrer
des chercheurs qui s'intéressent à ces
questions qui se penche là-dessus voir
un peu comment il aborde le problème
quels sont les défis qu'ils rencontrent
dans l'élaboration de traitements et
vaccins contre ce coronavirus et puis
voit on est allé donc pour faire ça dans
deux endroits différents
3la trois équipes de recherche mais deux
endroits à saskatoon et à québec où il
ya des centres de recherche qui sont
spécialisés dans la recherche sur ce
qu'on appelle les virus émergents où les
pathogènes émergents donc c'est leur
mission de travailler là dessus on a
voulu voir comment ça se passait là
dessus ouh là bas où évidemment cette
score aux navires us avec déplacions
l'imaginent sur le dessus de la pile
puis de moigny saab est assez spécial de
les rencontrer dans les circonstances
actuelles que qu'est ce que vous avez
ressenti de leur part mais on sent
évidemment un certain sentiment
d'urgence bien entendu les scientifiques
travaillent pas toujours dans l'urgence
mais ils ressentent bien l'urgence que
provoque cette pandémie
on sent aussi un sentiment de ces gens
là ont une mission bien sûr ce sont eux
c'est leur spécialité travailler sur les
virus émergents donc ils se sentent
renforcés dans cette responsabilité
qu'ils ont envers envers la population
dans le fond parce que c'est leur
travail de nous protéger ultime ont donc
vraiment une espèce de fébrilité une
excitation aussi parce que c'est très
intéressant pour eux ça provoque une
curiosité et puis ils ont l'impression
aussi je voudrais de travailler dans un
effort global mondial il ya certaines
ces chercheurs qui ont participé par
exemple à l'organisation mondiale de la
santé le mois dernier à une grande
réunion qui aurait rassemblé les
chercheurs du monde entier pour essayer
de coordonner cet effort de recherche
est là pour avoir des résultats le plus
vite possible
donc c'est tout simple qui les anime en
ce moment soit inscrit dans vraiment
dans un mouvement mondial
alors regardons votre reportage
le monde est entré en guerre contre un
adversaire invisible face à la pandémie
de kobe de 19 les moyens déployés sont
radicaux et parfois désespérée
aux grands maux les grands remèdes
seulement voilà le remède il n'en existe
encore aucun contre le nouveau
coronavirus pour y remédier les
scientifiques sont en première ligne
nous avons suivi trois équipes qui sont
entrés dans la course aux médicaments et
aux vaccins contre la maladie
celle de guarico beger directeur du
centre de recherche en infectiologie du
chul québec de son collègue
l'infectiologue guy boivin et du
microbiologiste dayraut bazar à nous
merci la saskatchewan
c'est vraiment tout le monde sur le pont
on travaille sans arrêt autant qu'on
peut et aussi vite qu'on plus la tâche
est immense il faut décoder le virus
comprendre son fonctionnement
dans quel tissu il se reproduit les
terminer quels animaux de laboratoire il
peut infecter tout ça dans l'espoir de
contrer garica bunker n'en est pas à sa
première crise sanitaire
il a contribué à mettre au point un
traitement et un vaccin contre la
maladie et mollahs il a travaillé sur le
gic la dirai pas chaîne l'urgence il
connaît c'est des moments importants
c'est que c'est sûr qu'il ya une once à
l'énergie puis évidemment on va faire
tout ce qu'on peut le plus rapidement
possible dès lé début de l'épidémie son
équipe s'est lancé à la recherche d'un
vaccin
encore un virus c'est du matériel
génétique
entouré d'une enveloppe surmonter deux
protéines qui forment comme une couronne
d'où son nom de corona pour qu'un vaccin
fonctionne il faut qu'il apprenne à
notre système immunitaire à reconnaître
ce virus pour mieux le détruire
pour y arriver on peut utiliser le virus
si ou encore une plusieurs de ces partis
caricom hunger planche sur quatre
méthodes différentes à la fois
pour qu'on puisse en bout de ligne à
avoir le plus possible de données sur le
plus possible de stratégie puis choisir
à travers ça le plus vite possible
quelques candidats qui vont pouvoir
avancer plus rapidement vers
l'application clinique
oui on en a des vaccins et des
traitements qu'on peut on peut générer
en quelques semaines
mais est-ce qu'on peut les amener
jusqu'au gens jusqu'à sauver des vies en
quelques semaines ou en quelques mois
c'est ça la grosse question développer
un vaccin
ça prend du temps il faut créer le
produit mais aussi le tester en
plusieurs étapes sur des animaux d'abord
puis sur des humains pour s'assurer
qu'il n'est pas dangereux et qu'il est
efficace
puis il faut le produire en quantité
suffisante et enfin l'administré aux
populations vulnérables à saskatoon les
jeunes à chenôve vaccine center a pour
vocation de développer des vaccins
contre les maladies émergentes dans l'un
de ces sept laboratoire dédié à l'étude
des pathogènes dangereux des relances
zaranou et son équipe font croître le
virus qui servira à tester l'efficacité
de leur vaccin expérimental leurs
produits visent une protéine à la
surface du virus
appelée protéine spike c'est la clé qui
permet au virus d'entrer dans les
cellules pour les infectés
[Musique]
c'est la preuve qu'à peu près tout le
monde privilégie mais il ya plusieurs
façon de s'y prendre
et tant mieux si ces différents groupes
s'y mettre parce qu'on ne sait pas
vraiment à quoi devrait ressembler un
vaccin contre le coronavirus il n'en
existe aucun jusqu'à il ya quelques
semaines les chercheurs travaillaient
sur un autre coronavirus celui du
syndrome respiratoire du moyen orient
depuis 2012 ce virus transmis par les
dromadaires a tué plus de 800 personnes
surtout dans la péninsule arabique
or on n'a toujours pas de vaccin pour le
contrer
ça fait cinq ans qu'on travaille sur un
vaccin quand ce jour coronavirus
moyen-orient n'est pas encore prêt à
être utilisé en accélérant les choses on
parle d'un minimum d'un an ou un an et
demi pour un vaccin contre le nouveau
coronavirus et je ne vois pas comment on
pourrait faire un retour à québec où
l'équipe du dr guy boivin fait lé point
ici en attendant et vaccins on espère
identifier des médicaments qui pourrait
soigner la maladie
les antiviraux qu'on a développée par
exemple contre la grippe le tamiflu dont
on entend souvent parler c'est une
protéine du virus de la grippe très
spécifique alors qu'ils présentent
nécessairement suite qu'on a virus donc
c'est pour ça qu'il faut développer des
cordes et des traitements qui sont
spécifiques à chacune des espèces de
virus
heureux hasard un tout nouveau
laboratoire de confinement a été
inaugurée en pleine crise du coronavirus
il était destiné à l'étude dangereux
virus de la grippe aviaire
les chercheurs ont changé de cible nous
on fait ce qu'on appelle du
repositionnement thérapeutique
alors c'est quoi le repositionnement
thérapeutique c'est de prendre un
médicament qui indications en clinique x
et trouver une veine indications il
direct n'est pas n'était pas connu
jusqu'à maintenant il faut savoir que
cette approche nous permet de nager
beaucoup plus rapidement de développer
beaucoup plus rapidement enchaîné
ailleurs des dizaines de ces cliniques
ont déjà commencé pour tester des
traitements contre la queue vite 19
de nombreux gouvernements et
institutions ont débloqué des fonds
d'urgence pour appuyer ses recherches
pour les scientifiques c'est une bonne
nouvelle mais ils sont unanimes c'est un
combat qu'il faudra mener sur le long
terme ce qui se fait aujourd'hui en
vaccinologie compte ce qu'auront à
vireux cela est très important pour le
futur parce que qu'il faudra pas arrêtée
l'année prochaine ou dans six mois ou
dans deux mois on espère tous qu'il va
arrêter mais il faut continuer pour
qu'on avance donc la prochaine fois mais
on soit paix on commence à comprendre
que si l'équipe virus qui vont sauter la
barrière des espèces en étant plus ou
moins rapproché
il faut être prêt il faut être prêt
avant
à kébili commence
le sprint qui a commencé devra sans
doute se transformer en marathon ouais
très instructif et gaël est ce qu est ce
qu a la chance de pouvoir battre de
vitesse cette pandémie fait toutes ces
recherches
ça va dépendre de la pandémie elle-même
mais on ne sait pas comment ça va se
dérouler est ce que sa vie relève
tranquillement disparaître avec le
retour des beaux jours on en rêve tous
est ce que c'est une tempête contre
laquelle l'humanité votre voir baisser
la tête et attendre que ça passe
c'est à suivre évidemment mais les
chercheurs pour eux en tout cas les de
fortes chances qu'on est le traitement
avant d'avoir un vaccin qui prendra lui
plus de temps et aussi c'est ce qu'il
disait dans le reportage c'est ce que
madame le maire a évoqué tout à l'heure
c'est une course qu'il faut mener sur le
long terme et ne pas lâcher on a eu le
strass en 2002-2003 ont eu le syndrome
respiratoire du moyen-orient les moyens
pour combattre ces hommes en descendent
monde descendre mais on sait que les
coronavirus sont capables de pandémie
oui comme les virus de l'influenza et
c'est de la recherche qu'il faut faire
pour que la prochaine fois ci c'est pas
pour cette fois ci au moins la prochaine
fois on soit prêt effectivement très
bons conseils
la réaction de vous tous c'est ce qu'on
va tirer les leçons
une fois pour toutes mais mature vos
réactions ce reportage dans ma réalité
des chercheurs mais c'est à dire que les
on a des chercheurs de niveau
international des grands chercheurs qui
travaillent très fort il faut les
soutenir
il n'y a aucun doute ils font de leur
mieux mais encore une fois les tests
cliniques prennent du temps le
développement de vaccins même essayer
des médicaments qui existe déjà pour
voir leur efficacité contre ce virus là
prennent du temps et donc est donc le
mieux qu'on peut faire ces temps ci
c'est soutenir non chercheurs on peut
toujours faire plus
on peut toujours faire plus et encore
une fois à aplatir la courbe pour avoir
moins de monde infectés en même temps
moi ce que je vous dirai ce qui est
quand même intéressant et qu'il faut
remettre en perspective c'est que
l'histoire on a connu pleine pandémie
alors on nous dit est-ce qu'on va s'en
sortir on va forcément s'en sortir
puisqu'on est la résultante aujourd'hui
de toutes ces pandémies historique faut
pas oublier qu'au québec on a eu des
épidémies de choléra de rouge
et caetera qui ont été très importantes
mais on a fini par s'en sortir avec peu
de moyens évidemment on veut pas revivre
ça en vie dans une nouvelle société avec
un nouveau monde où on a des moyens
beaucoup plus considérable mais on a une
société aussi qui s'attendraient des
résultats beaucoup plus rapide et
beaucoup plus immédiats que ce qu'on
avait dans le passé et c'est un petit
peu aussi ce paradoxe alors on a de très
bonnes équipes
l'équipe du docteur boivin designer
cours bingöl sont des équipes
internationalement reconnu qui ont
travaillé sur ebola mais il faut
travailler mais il faut aussi donner le
temps c'est une course contre la montre
mais on peut pas non plus à arrondir les
coins ronds mais moi je pense que
raisons d'être optimiste parce qu'on a
on commence à apprendre du passé parce
que les trois vaccins qui sont
maintenant prêts à entrer dans l'essai
clinique au niveau de la planète
un d'entre eux est un des vaccins qu'on
avait développé pour le strass et puis
qu'on avait laissé tomber justement
parce que l'épidémie était fort et
s'était estompé et on a repris la même
technologie on a changé la séquence pour
en mettre la séquence du nouveau
coronavirus et ce vaccin là est prête à
entrer en essai clinique dans le
prochain mois
c'est du jamais vu ça on n'a jamais été
aussi vite que ce soit pour développer
des candidats au vaccin il y en a deux
autres qu'on va déjà prêt à tester avec
moi je pense qu'il faut mettre les
choses en perspective dans le sens de
nos attentes par rapport à ce qu'on peut
faire pour un nouveau médicament ou un
nouveau vaccin
comment ferez-vous sur ses angoisses
souci que l'absence de traitement et de
vaccins pour le moment oui mais je
dirais reprenons le la métaphore du
marathon 1 d'ici un an d'ici le prochain
vaccin d'ici la prochaine solution
nous devons tous courir c'est à dire que
la prévention se fait au niveau chaque
individu chaque famille et chaque
société et ça nous avons des données là
dessus et donc le facteur humain et nos
connaissances sur l'humain doivent nous
permettre de nous mobiliser pour
attendre soit que ça mais pas l'attendre
de façon passive l'attendre dans un hall
dans une position nous savons que nous
pouvons diminuer la transmission ne
pouvons pas vaincre le virus n'est pas
nous pouvons l'embêter grandement d'où
la distanciation charlène question bien
la question est un état d'âme
quelle est la démarche de la communauté
scientifique internationale le niveau de
synergies de coordination dans la
recherche du vaccin les maires qu'en
pensez vous je pense que c'est un niveau
ou à extraordinairement élevé vous avez
évoqué dans votre reportage la réunion
qui s'est fait à genève
chapeauté par l'organisation mondiale de
la santé à laquelle ont participé
plusieurs chercheurs du monde hanté
entier et il ya eu une espèce d'entente
basé sur les spécialités les expertises
de chaque payer s quelle partie de la
question de la problématique
ils vont se concentrer là dessus alors
pour le canada c'était le développement
par exemple de vaccins puisqu'on a des
expertises là dedans et d'anti
d'antiviraux ce qu'on est en train de
faire les chercheurs sont en
communication il ya un site qui août ou
le monde mais ces résultats et
d'ailleurs avec 12,2 mais vis-à-vis
internationaux nous avons lancé un appel
par lettre ouverte
encore une fois à tous les tous les
éditeurs pour que les recherches les
résultats les données sur le coc u19
soit rendu public a deux façons la
science ouverte là pour que tout pour
que ça puisse accélérer la recherche et
l'innovation
donc c'est solidarité internationale
valeurs porteuses d'espoir c'est clair
dans quelle mesure on peut se fier
notamment peut-être sur la chine qui a
exploré que sans doute elle aussi fait
une mobilisation scientifique qui nous
en apprend beaucoup
est-ce qu'on a des échanges est ce qu
ont travaillé en collaboration même je
vous dirais qu'au niveau scientifique
que scientifique tout le monde travaille
ensemble
c'est quand même assez inusité que la
chine a rendu la séquence public s'il
n'avait pas rendu plus on danse qui ont
pas rendues publiques par la récession
les gens arrêter les gens forcés d'être
en quarantaine ils ont utilisé des
méthodes dictatoriales si on veut mais
combien d'autres
dans certains cas ont été efficaces et
qui ont permis justement actuellement de
voir les cadres diminués diminuer de
jour en jour de semaine en semaine ce
cas-ci remarqua pour un pays aussi
énorme ça il faut quand même souligner
dictature à part la wii eh bien personne
ils sont passés quand même au pic de la
crise 2500k de plus juste dans la
couronne à 15 de plus dans toute la
chine
c'est quand même assez remarquable
maladresse elle se soulève et ça je
pense que c'est très important
donc le coût social juste quelques ou
est-ce que nous sommes prêts à payer
pour diminuer la transmission et pour
enrayer l'épidémie et qu'elles sont et
là on fera appel de nouveau la
solidarité et la cohésion sociale
est ce que nous sommes capables de nous
mobiliser sans y être contraints c'est
une grosse c'est une grosse vidéo avec
les réactions vous voyez est ce que je
pense qu'il faut en prendre les moyens
c'est à dire que la solidarité où la
cohésion
ça n'arrive pas juste comme ça il faut
la créer et je pense que c'est donc nous
nous mobilisons au niveau scientifique
j'en appelle à une mobilisation au
niveau social donc comment est ce que
nous arrivons à créer dans cette
épidémie une cohésion pour que chacun se
sente concerné non maintenant une
blessure est mince on sait par les
personnes âgées de leurs proches
on a vu cette dame tout à l'heure qui
disait ce que je veux savoir ce que je
vais mourir moi puis ainsi que les
personnes âgées qui se retrouve
complètement isolé c'est comme si on les
abandonnait on fait le contraire on
parle d'arrêter mon les abandonnent des
gens très malades dans les hôpitaux qui
se retrouvent seuls privés de visites
sur ma tante à l'article abonnez-vous
lala ont dix ans - on sépare les gens
puis on va en même temps de solidaires
comment y arriver il faudrait mettre en
cause peut-être juste simplement parce
qu'il vient de sortir un article dans le
land 7 qui est quand même une bonne
vue sur cette question là donc on sait
qu'un des effets principal de la
quarantaine le principal problème c'est
l'isolément
or là on est en train de créer
énormément énormément d'isolement mais
les études ont souvent été fait avant
l'explosion des médias sociaux
alors je pense qu'il faut être inventif
on ne peut pas ne pas isoler mais
comment pouvons-nous isolé en maintenant
des liens
je pense qu'il faut être inventif à ce
niveau là pour justement que les
personnes âgées puissent parler avec
leurs enfants et leurs petits enfants
par sky par téléphone qu'on maintienne
le lien parce que ce lien est important
à la vie ouais mettre la technologie au
profit vous comme conseillère en chef du
canada si vous pouviez nous dire quelles
sont vos priorités en ce moment donné
parce qu'il ya josée pelletier parce que
c'est une question c'est pour madame le
maire nous écrire avec vous une idée du
nombre de mois que cette crise pourrait
durer on sait que ça va être long pour
le vaccin charme oscars est long pour un
traitement mais ça ça dure des mois vous
devez aussi mené avec le chef
d'orchestre la chef d'orchestre de cette
course contrairement au club ben c'est
un grand bond en arrière alors pas là
monsieur trudeau ou à ses représentants
parce que vous avez un téléphone rouge
je pense que certains excès qu'est ce
que vous dites quoi moi mon rôle c'est
vraiment de fournir les avis
scientifiques au gouvernement m'assurer
que les décisions sont prises sur la
base de faits probants alors c'est sûr
que ss bouleverse
à fur et à mesure qu'on en apprend plus
etc mais mais si ça va durer quelques
mois il va falloir être aux aguets
moment donné on espère pouvoir contenir
n'est ce pas là la propagation de la
maladie et donc à ce moment là il va
falloir poser d'autres questions qui ont
été créés par cette douce et la base
scientifique c'est par exemple la
question est beaucoup soulevées sur la
fameuse question des frontières
monsieur legault le demande on se pose
la question des déplacements
interprovinciaux la question se pose
même aux etats-unis c'est les voyages
intérieurs quand même
les gens se disent les gens viennent de
l'étranger on les laisse rentrer puis
nous on nous met en quarantaine
la question des frontières c'est un
choix économique et politique mais sur
la base scientifique est ce que ce genre
de vie que vous que vous
suggérer de faire ou pas est ce que est
ce qu'on veut ce que mon pose la
question est ce qu'il ya des données
scientifiques la réponse est absolument
oui d'ailleurs les que les études
montrent c'est que si on arrête le
trafic et les voyages on va pas enrayer
l'épidémie mais on va la retarder et
retardé c'est un peu ce qu'on est en
train de souhaiter en ce moment donc je
crois que moment donné il y a des bases
scientifiques pour prendre certaines
mesures qu'on n'a pas peut-être jugé
utile de prendre au début au tout début
quand on avait un os 3 ou 5
n'est ce pas parce qu'il ya toujours une
balance du pour et du contre
donc d'ailleurs aujourd'hui même plus
tôt dans la journée je parlais avec la
vice première ministre donc qui m'a posé
plusieurs questions avant la rencontre
du du cabinet de c'est ça justement qui
a porté sur plusieurs éléments dont les
bases scientifiques par exemple pour les
voyages donc en conclusion si on suggère
son du gouvernement et des bases
scientifiques qui disent que si on
réduit les voyages ou s'ils ont fermé
certains circuits peut-être pas toutes
les frontières on améliore nos chances
l'affiché les gens disent c'est trop
tard le déjà puisque vous en dit je ne
crois pas qu'il est trop tard pour faire
quoi que ce soit pour cette pandémie
n'est ce pas donc on va toujours devoir
prendre des mesures qu'on n'a pas prise
la veille et etc
donc je dirais qu'il n'est pas trop tard
je crois que ce qui est aussi important
de réaliser quand on parle de fermer les
frontières c'est un grand monde n'est ce
pas est ce qu on en paie on n'empêchera
pas par exemple et canadien de revenir
au pays
bon les touristes peut-être ça rentre un
peu dans ce qui peut être retardée et
certainement ce qu'on veut s'assurer
c'est qu'on a tout le matériel dont on a
besoin au pays donc pas question
peut-être de fermer les frontières n'est
ce pas au trafic des marchandises
oui mais d'abord des gens pour
accueillir
on va revenir à ce sujet ce sujet chaud
parce que julie à des questions car je
voudrais vraiment mari charles et nos
différents intervenants qui est avec
nous ce soir c'est un sujet qui touche
beaucoup de gens et qui les interpelle
aussi leur esprit critique leur esprit
scientifique
encore une fois les adresses pour nous
contacter si vous souhaitez le faire
vous êtes des centaines à nous écrire
depuis le début de l'émission mais voici
comment le faire sur twitter avec le
comte radio-canada info par courriel
24-70 obas radio canada.ca
et vous pouvez bien sûr nous écrire
commenté réfléchir en fait poser toutes
sortes de questions sur la page facebook
de radio-canada info voici donc de
toutes ces questions adressées à nos
panélistes à nos intervenants sur le
plateau lise bouchard de laval qui nous
écrit quand cet épisode aigu de la
pandémie dans lequel nous sommes sera
passée cette menace virale va-t-elle
persister dans le temps et si oui dans
quelle mesure madame bouchard ajoute
comment contenir le virus et éviter la
sévérité d'une autre vague d'éclosion
avant justement l'existence la
distribution d'un vaccin ou encore d'un
traitement
seconde question avant de vous laisser
la parole victor marchand de saturne qui
nous la peau celle ci et nous dit vous
savez il ya beaucoup d'informations
médicales vraiment en épidémiologie qui
nous sont fournis mais peu
d'informations souligne-t-il sous forme
de la pneumologie à fait se prémunir
justement contre l'inflammation
pulmonaire qui est parfois fatales et
donc causé par ce virus pouvez vous s'il
vous plaît insister sur cet élément
demande-t-il
je vous laisse donc sur cette question
de monsieur marchande sont unis on
représentera la précédente d'après lui
alors peut-être une question
intéressante en réalité on n'a pas la
réponse est pas juste pour ce virus là
on l'a pas pour tout l'inflammation
pulmonaire quand on fait des syndromes
de détresse respiratoire
on sait que c'est souvent une tempête
inflammatoires cette année c'est pas le
virus lui même qui cause directement le
problème c'est les conséquences de
l'infection par le virus est un peu
notre système immunitaire qui perd entre
guillemets son autorégulation
et là vous avez toutes sortes de formes
de marqueurs de l'inflammation qui vont
détruire finalement nos propres poumons
alors comment est-ce qu'on contrôle ça
il ya parce qu'il n'ya pas juste c'est
ce syndrome de détresse respiratoire est
associé à beaucoup d'autres choses
il n'y a pas juste ce virus dont on n'a
pas de moyens connus et fille
ce qu'on peut utiliser il ya beaucoup de
choses qui ont été tentées mais il n'y a
rien qui à date on va dire a été réussie
parce que la recherche que c'est là
dessus maintenant oui il ya de la
recherche qui se fait là dessus mais ce
que je dirai je vous dirais c'est que
c'est un nouveau virus
et puis c'est très intéressante de
comprendre aussi les comorbidités
comment ça se fait que les gens qui ont
des problèmes cardiaques
des problèmes respiratoires sont plus à
risque et je lisais justement ce matin
un article scientifique qui vient de
paraître
on a beaucoup parlé du de la clé de la
serrure et donc le virus utilise des
protéines qui sont importantes là pour
le système aussi cardio vasculaires et
on comprend pas vous comprenez toute la
chaîne des événements le corps va pas
bien les poumons vont pas bien ne
pouvons nous avons pas bien elle ne va
pas bien et c'est il ya aussi un point
très important dont on parle pas souvent
mais qui est peut-être important à
explorer il ya des gens qu'ils font dans
le monde c'est l'aspect génétique est ce
qu'il ya des marqueurs génétiques chez
des individus qui font qu'ils sont plus
à risque de développer une maladie c'est
une prédisposition sévère par rapport à
d'autres et ça on ne sait pas vraiment
si on passe à lacq et à la question si
vous voulez bien comment éviter
l'avènement l'arrivée d'un autre virus
oui il ya une question qui me taraude la
le strass a commencé comme ça cette
épidémie a commencé de la même façon la
vente d'animaux sauvages en vente libre
dans certains pays du monde
est ce que on parle de cette solidarité
pour la recherche mais il ya une
solidarité aussi politique et
diplomatique qui doit être exercice
madame est ce que ce serait logique
d'essayer de ce guide errements et de
façon mondial de convaincre les pays qui
agissent encore de cette façon là de ne
plus le faire pour que pour que ce type
de virus qui viennent surgir ne puisse
pas ressurgir dans deux ou trois ans de
la même façon et que ça nous prennent
encore des mois et des mois à trouver le
vaccin a trouvé l'antiviral etc
écoutez c'est sûr qu'on est en train
d'apprendre la qos et virus là peuvent
passer
des animaux à l'humain puis ensuite se
transmettre de l'humain à l'humain on
sait pas d'ailleurs si on les retransmet
à d'autres animaux sous une autre forme
parce qu'on a beaucoup parlé de strass
on pense que le strass a disparu mais je
vous rappelle juste que ce nouveau virus
dont on parle est très apparentes et
c'est un cousin germain je vous irez au
strass et la question est-ce que c'est
finalement le sera ce qui s'est invité
au point qu'on le reconnaît plus et qui
est devenu ce nouveau virus
donc oui il faut apprendre il faut
apprendre les mesures qu'il faut mais le
reste on n'est quand même pas pour dire
à d'autres pays quoi faire avant de
prendre les mêmes chances que la chine a
déjà éperdue surgit une bible c'était
déjà interdit au départ mais avec mes
mais il faut pas penser qu' il ne se
produire plus de d'incidents comme ça
dans le futur des zones aux salles
existait depuis la nuit des temps
notre corps humain est fait de deux
pleines virus qu'on a intégré au cours
des millénaires aider et il voyait
toujours d'avoir des zones aux donc des
maladies qui passe d'une espèce en
vendant une autre espèce que y'a pas
grand chose qu'on peut faire qui voit
éviter ça on peut en éviter certains
types par des pratiques d'hygiène des
pratiques meilleur mais ça empêche repos
qu'un animal dans sauvage éventuellement
pourrait transmettre à un être humain
une autre maladie piquerez donc je pense
un peu illusoire de penser qu'il y aura
plus d'autres événements comme ceux
mieux vaut penser qu'il va y en avoir
d'autres
et puis d'être préparés à ce genre
d'événement parce que c'est plus sur
l'évolution humaine normale mais les
gens la maison peut se demander pourquoi
cette fois-ci par rapport aux strass à
l'épaule à auzon pourquoi le monde est
paralysée là c'est la france ferme tous
là nous l'italie a fermé tous l'année
c'est arrivé c'est arrivé dans le passé
sont également à l'influenza de 14 ne
l'est plus 1 1 la grille espagnol c'est
arrivé
oui ça fait son temps mais le h1n1 le
virus s'est répandu à travers la planète
il n'était pas aussi sévère heureusement
mais il s'est répandu à travers la
planète
donc ce sont des événements qui risque
d'arriver en quarts alors je pense c'est
mieux de penser de cette façon là de
savoir que ce sont des événements qui
risque d'arriver en quarts et de se
préparer mais une différence importante
avec leur chien aussi c'est que vos
achats on avait des médicaments puis on
avait un vaccin dont on pouvait jusqu'à
un certain point combattre si vous
voulez le virus ce qu'on n'a pas ici et
on voit qu'il ya une évolution
importante il ya un taux de mortalité
plus élevé c'est donc normal que les
gouvernements à un moment donné se pose
la question de comment je vais protéger
les populations très important alors j
ai mon a pour nous charles de nouvelles
qu'elles sont peut-être sur un thème qui
est extrêmement important d'aborder on
met les gens les allemands ou en
quarantaine les gens se demandent
comment vivre cette nouvelle situation
on a eu des indices d'une forme
d'hystérie ou de panico d'inquiétude
mais comment y arriver à vivre tout ça
julie oui anne marie charles on a des
questions à propos de l' angoisse vous
savez et de comment bien transmettre le
message aux différentes clientèles aux
différentes strates de la population ni
plus ni moins j'ai eu avec cette
première de nathalie girard de métier
sur mer qui nous écrit peut-être
concernant le groupe des ados madame
rousseau vous l'avez évoqué un petit peu
en début d'émission mais on poursuit en
ce sens madame girard demande on incite
les jeunes à ne pas croire tout ce qui
est véhiculé sur le web ou dans certains
médias elle fait donc référence à ces
fameuses forces nouvelles comment leur
faire comprendre à ces jeunes que la
menace actuelle et sérieuse comment
surtout les persuader que ce n'est pas
l'occasion de voyager ou encore de
profiter de ce congé avec leurs amis
donc première question la seconde à
voici louise mcnicoll de québec
hélas je me sens directement interpellé
en tant que maman de deux jeunes enfants
beaucoup de parents aussi qui sont à
l'écouté
voici la question dans la mecque nicole
comment expliquer ce qui se passe en ce
moment aux enfants surtout les plus
anxieux demande-t-elle sachant que le
virus est invisible pour la plupart
d'entre nous comment leur faire
comprendre que leurs activités sont
annulées que leur routine sont perturbés
bouleversé qu'il faut éviter de même
côtoyé ses proches d'aller voir grand
papa grand maman de se faire garder
peut-être par d'autres membres de la
famille le tout sans les inquiéter à
outrance et enfin troisième question
dans le même sens de l' angoisse celle
de madame saint-yves qui nous écrit sur
facebook j'aimerais qu'on explique bien
à nos aînés qu'on leur explique vraiment
de manière très claire
comment se protéger afin qu'ils se
sentent rassurés surtout qu'il sache
quoi faire
et encore une fois il ne mérite pas un
tel stress ajoute t-il donc on est
vraiment dans l' angoisse dans l'aspect
stress de l'agencé régionale et cela
pose la question de la compréhension de
la clarté des mesures annoncées
c'est l'os autres on peut en parler avec
vos également parce que l'exemple des
grands parents ils ont des enfants qui
ont tu dois continuer à travailler son
nom la santé devant des médias ou
autrement
et là qu'est ce qu'on fait avec les
enfants les gardiens sont fermées est ce
que des personnes âgées peuvent garder
des enfants
la question était arrivés des dizaines
de fois alors d'avoir toutes ces
questions sont très importantes je pense
qu'il ya une mesure qui est plus
transversale donc qui nous concerne tous
en fait même nous qui sommes
spécialistes
l'information est importante elle est le
nerf de la guerre mais trop
d'informations cet angoissant
la première recommandation pour les
jeunes enfants
c'est fermer la télévision ça n'est pas
bon pour des enfants d'être exposés à
ces contenus toute la journée ça n'est
pas bon pour nous d'être exposés enfin
ne nous apprend rien donc travailler là
dessus
regardez ça quelques heures par jour et
pour les aînés je pense être au courant
et regarder une ou deux heures de kovy
d'un jour c'est correct mais douze
heures dans une journée
c'est bon pour personne dont je pense
qu'il ya la question de ceux de réguler
notre exposition au stress
ça c'est important ensuite au niveau des
adolescents je pense que la question
qu'il faut se poser ça ça peut dépendre
des milieux en région peut-être pas la
même chose qu'à montréal ou dans
certaines communautés a pointé à charge
c'est pas la même chose qu'à autrement
donc quelles sont les sources et les
personnes crédibles pour les jeunes je
pense qu'il faut mobiliser ces jeunes-là
est mobilisée ces gens là qui sont pas
forcément des jeunes dans ce qui se
passe actuellement pour se dire qu'est
ce qui fait que les jeunes vont pouvoir
se prendre sérieusement nous prendre
sérieusement vous savez c'est un peu
comme le débat sur les drogues
quand les adultes dit non les jeunes
vont ainsi et quand même et je pense que
là pour le coup vide
la question c'est de dire écoutez
regardez chercher et on va en discuter
donc l'esprit critique face développe ça
s'apprend je pense que le fait de
reprendre en main donc ses connaissances
en disant pourquoi vous pensez que ça
c'est vrai pourquoi vous pensez que ça
c'est pas vrai vous voulez voyager
regard regardons ça donc il faut je
pense qu'il faut discuter avec les
jeunes plus qu imposer il faut discuter
à partir d' interlocuteur crédible
on peut peut-être avoir la première qui
avait positionné
je me posais cette question suivante
est-ce que vous pensez que les médias
sont allés trop loin vous savez on dit
dans notre milieu surtout dans les
nouvelles continue il faut nourrir la
bête vous nourrir la bête dès qu'il ya
du nouveau des cas une information des
cayes nouvelles ont bien sûr
ils on s'assure qu'il est rigoureux soit
exacte non mais oh non et je parle pas
nécessairement de notre réseau des
réseaux en général
est ce que on aurait dû avoir plus de
retenue
est-ce que ça a contribué à créer une
peur en particulier chez des enfants et
leurs parents
oui nos systèmes d'information tels
qu'ils sont a cause de la brièveté des
nouvelles de l'absence de discussions un
génère des messages chocs qui passe
mieux mais qui suscite plus de peur donc
plus un messager du ans et complexes -
un sujet de peur mais moi ils suscitent
d'intérêt aussi et là vous serez
contradictoires donc les messages courts
lapidaire su style de là c'est plus de
peur suscite aussi plus d'incrédulité et
je pense que aulas à ce niveau là la
question c'est qu'ils parlent quitté qui
est crédible
le problème pour les jeunes pour les
tout petits c'est qu'en fait très
souvent on pense qu'ils ne comprennent
pas et donc les parents sont anxieux et
regarde la télé et ils ne vont pas
expliquer aux enfants ce qui se passe
dans des termes c'est à dire toi des
fois tu es malade
la fièvre arrêt que tous et puis
peut-être tes amis peuvent l'attraper
mais là si ça t'arrive
eh bien ça peut être ça peut être
embêtant pour papier pour manille pour
et caetera et c'est pour ça qu'on reste
ici et on va y rester ici qu'un jour et
il faut réorganiser cet espace de 15
jours le planifier comment planifier des
vacances comment planifier l'école pour
rétablir une routine ans lève en se
lavant des jeunes qu'est ce qu'on fait
après que ce soit planifiée ça c'est
très rassurant parce que ça veut dire
que la vie est prévisible que pensez
vous de la réaction généralement face à
l'information qui diffusait face à la
désinformation également parce qu'il y
en a beaucoup de départager le vrai du
faux parce qu'il ya même sur nos dos
message que nous recevons des gens qui
nous voyons donc il n'y en a pas grave
y'a pas beaucoup de monopoly on n'est
pas la chaîne
alors comment même les adultes
doivent-ils être persuadé que c'est une
menace sérieuse
bien bien je pense que ce que dr sur dix
est important c'est à dire il faut
toujours répéter le même message qui
quand même important de faire parce que
quelqu'un au pull d'écouté ya deux jours
puis était pas prête dans danse avec la
recevoir ce message là et puis là il
connaît quelqu'un qui était mis en
isolement
puis loeb va s'intéresser plus son
message aujourd'hui donc le message doit
être répétée mais aussi discuter donc
faut que ce soit quelque chose qui se
comprennent par exemple on nomme c'est
vrai qu'on a parlé beaucoup d'isolement
volontaire sens bien décrire qu'est ce
que ça veut dire pour une version diesel
c'est comme si j'ai entendu des gens
dire on lit mais en prison où on va être
obligé de ce que ça peut être perçu
différemment les gens tous les pas
comment on décide qu'on va vivre sa pipe
même madame d'y planifier son isolement
volontaire comme on planifie ses
vacances je pense est la meilleure à
chaque jour sa survie de jours vélo oui
mais c'est l'europe par exemple c'est le
temps de cuisiner des belles recettes
qu'on avait jamais le temps de faire
quand on travaillait
c'est le temps de penser à ses parents
âgés et puis de leur mémoire mais qu'on
peut donner des coups de feu ont pu
aller les voir pelé les voies puis on
peut aller leur faire des diplomates les
laisser ouvrir la porte puis les
serristes à 2 m 2 et puis les saluer et
puis tout ça c'est pas la coupure
drastique
on peut sortir de apprend de faire
marcher le chien on peut jouer dehors
d'un code des enfants donc c'est pas la
prison là c'est c'est comme deux
semaines de livres en fait qu'on peut
planifié comme on veut en respectant les
consignes puis la logique de l'
isolement qui est de ne pas de ne pas
rencontrer d'autres personnes donc ce
pôle temps d'organiser des parties
ça c'est sûr même les mariages les
funérailles et n'en sais rien c'est la
persistance du message parce que plus on
va avancer dans le temps plus les gens
vont réaliser la situation dans laquelle
on est et au bout d'un moment les ceux
qui sont le plus réfractaire fonds
finiront aussi par comprendre un petit
peu il ya aussi un aspect important
d'augmenter en plus normalement si on
regarde la courbe alors il faudrait
qu'ils aient vraiment cet aspect là
aussi de solidarité sociale
on garde une cohésion de société parce
que dans ce genre de choses là et on l'a
vu lorsque par exemple les gens la peur
ou lorsque le lap l'anxiété que ça peut
provoquer les gens changent de
comportement et on vit dans une société
qui n'a pas été habitué dans le passé à
ce genre de situation donc c'est nouveau
pour beaucoup de monde
la majorité des gens n'ont pas été
habitués à st donc c'est un
apprentissage aussi moi je dirais que
regarder vous avez eu des milliers de
questions alors de toute évidence les
gens veulent en savoir plus ils
demandent des informations et je crois
pas que c'est le moment d'être en guerre
avec avec nos médias crédibles je pense
qu'il joue un rôle très important parce
que la guerre c'est contre le virus est
exactement c'est contre le virus et non
contre la formation à qui et qui est
crédible
je crois que le point sur les messages
chocs est très court et certainement je
pense à retenir la que plus on explique
pourquoi le message choc et là c'est le
plus important ne faut pas oublier non
plus que la communication est dépendant
du contexte de la personne qui reçoit
l'information ce qui marche pour
certains ne marcherait pas sur d'autres
puis il faut vraiment s'assurer que les
divers usages de la société reçoivent le
message donc il faut faire du theil loin
que je dirais oui aussi du messager de
l'information parce que oui le risque de
visqueux
l'italien vécu l'espagne vit la france
est-ce qu'il irait elle will est réelle
mais regardez ce qui est intéressant en
italie les gens trouver d'autres façons
de se divertir ils ont commencé à
chanter à ouvrir leurs fenêtres
ils ont trouvé d'autres façons
finalement de rendre la vie plus facile
alors oui les réelles si à un moment
donné on avait un scénario un peu plus
catastrophique et qu on est on est en
train d'avancer tranquillement regarder
en enlever les écoles et barre des 6
donc à un moment donné les gens
commencent à se dire il ya de moins en
moins de choses à faire
alors nous a été plusieurs fois
mentionné c'est vient des personnes
âgées des couples de retraités qui sont
à l'étranger soit que son prix à
l'étranger qui peuvent pas rentrer et où
six au sucre sont en fleuret les fameux
snowbird ils se disent qu'est ce que je
fais ce que je reviens est-ce que je
respecte ma date de retour
comment je reviens puis qu'est ce qui
m'arrive quand je reviens que qu'est-ce
qu'on leur faisait là on leur dit de
revenir
je pense que le message était très clair
de la part du ministre du premier
ministre monsieur legault de revenir le
plus tôt possible
ceci dit ils ont des problèmes à se
trouver des vols pour pouvoir revenir
adéquatement donc je pense que le
message quand même qu'il revienne et
puis c'est là où l'esprit communautaire
doit doit entrer en ligne que donc la
famille préparent leur retour pour pas
qu'ils arrivent qui tombe comme un
cheveu sa soupe mais qu'il prépare un
beau hall au gigantisme en venir et puis
des provisions avez-vous des signes d'en
avoir des gens qui s'expriment dans la
part de patients de toutes générations
avez vous des craintes
est ce que c'est un traumatisme qui aura
des gens qui vont rester parce que de la
santé mentale est présent dans la
société que c'est qu'on l'a pourtant
dirigerait les crissements des
dépressifs les angoisses et les trop de
personnalité l'état car elle lorsque
vous soulevez un harry c'est qu'en fait
tout ça le stress des partis notre vie
donc ça un effet stressant pour tout le
monde et on peut tous en ressentir les
effets de temps en temps pour des
personnes plus vulnérables qui ont déjà
des problèmes
et emmental anxieux ou d'autres types
c'est certain que ça va aller ça risque
dans beaucoup de cas et on le voit déjà
d'accentuer ses angoisses là où cette
désorganisation des gens qui ont des
théories de la conspiration qui
s'identifier un ennemi vous savez une
relation donc qu'elle va être l'aîné est
ce que je suis en danger est ce que je
dois attaquer donc ça va exacerber des
problèmes de santé mentale préexistants
vallée moyer ça c'est important est
levée et l'autre chose et ça il faut le
penser ensemble c'est cet arrêt de deux
semaines va amener certains enfants qui
sont en fait
souffrant est difficile à rester avec
leurs parents hélas les services vont
être débordées donc il faut penser tous
les aspects de cette crise pour soutenir
les aînés bien sûr on parlait des aînés
mais aussi les enfants en difficulté qui
tout d'un coup en plus d'écoles se
retrouvent à la maison et toutes les
personnes avec des problèmes de santé
mentale
je pense qu'on en est à repenser des
façons inventives en essayant de limiter
les contacts mais pour continuer à
donner des services sentimentale en ce
moment c'est vraiment pas le moment de
couper là dedans on a besoin au
contraire d'un plus pour toute la
population mais aussi pour cette
population incroyable c'est ce qu'on va
investir pour des des chambres des
appareils respiratoires démasquer tous
là mais espérons convaincre la condition
mentale julie des questions 400 rafale
vraiment quatre courtes mais sur des
colts peu plus appliqué cette fois ci on
est moins dans la recherche des
questions spécifiques la première est ce
que le covilha le coronavirus les styles
des séquelles sur les poumons dont on
parle dans le plus long terme une fois
qu'on est rétabli qu'on est guéri un
mythe qu'on a ou du moins une
information qu'on a beaucoup vu passer
sur les réseaux sociaux
y at il un effet aggravant si on prends
des anti inflammatoires but la santé de
la france faisant exactement tout à fait
à marie est ce que les jeunes qui sont
immuno supprimés devraient se mettre en
isolement mon genou
samar jeunes en fait les gens
immunosupprimées et enfin devraient être
annulés d'autres types de soins médicaux
soins dans taisho ophtalmique
si ce n'est pas grave puisque en fait je
veux me lancer sur quelques-unes des
séquelles aux poumons les gens qui ont
la forme sévère de la maladie qui vont
présenter une réaction inflammatoire
dans les poumons peuvent avoir des
séquelles peuvent avoir de la fibrose
qui va se développer dans leurs poumons
si bien que par après leurs poumons
risque de fonctionner moins bien c'est
ça a été observée dans l'école analyse
des codes qui nous proviennent de chine
et puis c'est une complication que l'on
connaît de ce qu'on appelle ce syndrome
de détresse respiratoire mais l'on parle
des cas graves
uniquement des coqs qui ont la forme
sévère la deuxième question c'est est
sur l'eau les hanter la mémoire du beau
essayer de vérifier ça aujourd'hui pour
savoir quelles étaient les bases
scientifiques sur la recommandation du
ministre la santé de france de ne pas de
dire de ne pas utiliser d'anciens films
at war non stéroïdiens en fait il
s'avère que s'appuie sur une observation
médicale en france dans une hôpital où
ils ont eu 34 cas de maladie chez des
jeunes de maladies très sévère et que le
fil conducteur ce qu'ils avaient tous
pris des anti-inflammatoires non
stéroïdiens
ceci ne veut les jeunes bon je sais pas
ce qui faisait de la fièvre tout seul il
avait pris 10 ans corrosion un rhume
avec c'est ça alors ça établissant un
lien de causalité il faut être très très
prudent
c'est une association ceci dit certaines
bases théoriques qui pourrait être un
peu une une explication potentiel pour
ce type d'association l'homme et on n'en
sait pas plus alors je ne pense pas qu
ici on puisse émettre une recommandation
comme ceci dit on a d'autres médicaments
pour soulager les courbatures et faire
baisser la fièvre de l'acétaminophène
puis dans le doute pourquoi pas ceux y
aller avec la 7ème et 9ème plus excuser
moi
je ne sais pas si c'est pertinent mais
est ce que c'est une des façons de
caractériser la maladie d'un coït 19
kantien début d'inflammation pulmonaire
et le fait de prendre des
anti-inflammatoires ce que ça pourrait
masquer sa et laisser croire aux
cliniciens qui s'agit plutôt d'une
grippe autre chose
non probablement commencer vraiment
avait fait on peut pas de diviser
vraiment la maladie comme ça parce que
y'a des gens qui sont pas très malade
mes gars qui en a fait des radiographies
pulmonaires et qui seront pas trop et
malade même avec une radiographie
pulmonaire qui est un peu anormal
alors ça veut pas dire parce qu'on a une
radiographie pulmonaire qu'on va
toujours être très très malade
donc il ya toute une gamme dans la
sévérité de cette maladie l'a donc
souvent comme disait ma collègue c'est
parce que ces gens là prenez ça pour
masquer la fièvre mais peut-être aussi
que s'il faisait de la fièvre pendant
très très longtemps c'est parce qu'ils
avaient déjà aussi une forme plus sévère
de la maladie et ils ont donc pris plus
de médicaments donc qu'est-ce qui est
l'oeuf et qu'est-ce qui est la poule
dans l'histoire c'est pour ça que c'est
difficile de tirer des conclusions
tu te réponse rapide pour le jeune les
minots supprimé en isolement et annuler
les soins dentaires et tous les gens
tous les gens immuno supprimer l'eau
devait prendre des précautions très
particulière essayé de minimiser au
maximum les contacts avec l'extérieur
donc c'est de bonne guerre dentiste le
dax est je pense que personne n'a
tellement le goût de fête le temps de
reporter notre environnement
parce que des récépissés plus là le
contact social si on essaie de minimiser
les contacts sociaux alors si on n'a pas
besoin d'y aller
bon très bien alors le modèle on va se
retrouver tous les 4 après la pause avec
vous et charles
bien sûr parce que cette émission
spéciale était sur radio nadal se
poursuit sur air d'été l'est également
sur le facebook sur le web
alors si tout pour les auditeurs de 10,6
radio canada c'est elle et merci d'avoir
été avec nous pour remercier l'émission
découverte on a volé un peu le créneau
de toute l'équipe de découverte mais ils
découvrent un poseur nous avons un plan
mais ce soir l'invitée si
chaleureusement et dans la crise pour
nous participer
merci beaucoup d'être là vous aussi
merci echard vous allez avec moi bien
sûr ils se sont débrouillés bien sûr ce
résident réseaux sociaux très bien alors
je vais donc l'émission et vos questions
pour un peu vous accompagner dans cette
nouvelle vie avec les questions qui
seront présentés en ondes par julie et
n'ont donc au cours de la prochaine nous
allons également recevoir le ministre
fédéral jean yves duclos qui répondre à
nos questions parce qu'il ya eu un
conseil des ministres à ottawa
aujourd'hui si vous êtes abonnés au
câble on le dit serait débrouillé c'est
gratuitement pour tout le monde alors on
reconduit pour trouver après
[Musique]
re bonsoir mesdames messieurs si anne
marie dussault accompagné de charles
tisseyre l'animateur de découverte
cette émission spéciale coved 19
découverte en direction poursuit jusqu'à
21h l'idée c'est ben c'est de vous
accompagner dans cette nouvelle vie de
nouvelles réalités ce que ça va durer
deux semaines est ce que ça va durer
plus longtemps
comment la pandémie affecte votre vie
déjà vous nous avez fait parvenir des
centaines de questions soyons modestes
peut-être même au dessus de 1000
questions alors il ya beaucoup beaucoup
d'interrogations beaucoup de
d'inquiétude aussi et beaucoup d'espoir
en même temps comment la science aussi
va-t-elle nous permettre de vaincre
cette pandémie la conversation se
poursuit
je vous présente à nouveau mes experts
en rafale
dr cissé lô sous pédo psychiatre
spécialisé dans les questions de
clientèles à risque qui a vécu des
grands traumatismes d'accord cécile
tremblay microbiologiste au sud que leur
calvaire microbiologiste pardon
microbiologiste au jewish est aussi
président de l'association des
microbiologistes et madame mona nemer
conseillère en conseiller scientifique
en chef du canada je veux dire quelle
est la ligne rouge avec le gouvernement
pour suggérer d'investir dans la
recherche pour mettre beaucoup de
pression sur intéressant je pense que
l'ailier charles les téléspectateurs ont
couvert un personnage important de notre
vie scientifique et comment alors aussi
alors des questions maintenant
allons vous présenter avec julie qui
continue de les recevoir julie oui en
très grand nombre de marines sont là des
milliers maintenant je sais c'est moi
qui suis ça de très près sur les réseaux
sociaux mais effectivement des milliers
de questions nous sont envoyées depuis
le début de cette émission spéciale à
18h30 maintenant on y va avec
quelques-unes d'abord alain van den
bosch qui nous demande
lorsqu'on nous présente la fameuse
courbe qu'on cherche à aplatir justement
je comprends bien dit il que le but est
de les tirer de telle sorte à ne pas
dépasser ce seuil en cette capacité du
réseau de la santé à offrir tous nos
services aux personnes malades
avons-nous une idée de la durée que cela
prendrait pour maintenir cette courbe la
plus plate possible donc ils nous
demandent peut-être un aperçu de cette
cep durée sont les une échelle
temporelle
réponse je pense qu'il faut comprendre
que l'idée d'aplatir la courbe s'est
aussi d'espérer d'avoir moins de cas
parce que c'est pas de penser qu'on
l'appela ti comme ceux qui a cette fois
c'est que l'idée c'est de questions
diminue le pic de désinfection la voilà
on a moins d'infections qui se propage
donc on contamine moins deux personnes
au fur et à mesure puisqu'on parlait du
taux de reproduction le sillon une
personne en un fake 2 puis un moment
donné mais une personne en effet que
plus qu'une
on va diminuer aussi le nombre de cas
dans l'épidémie donc un double un double
message dans cette courbe que l'on doit
aplatir
c'est puis et quand les gens se
demandent ce qu'ils peuvent faire pour
aider à la pandémie mais il faut penser
à quelque chose si par le fait qu'on
respectent la consigne consommer en
isolement volontaire
nous on ne se fait pas infecté et donc
on empêche deux autres personnes d'être
infectés ça devient exponentielle
donc faut pas minimiser la contribution
que chaque individu chaque citoyen fait
à cette plate issement de la courbe
chaque infection qu'on évite ce n'est
les deux autres et éventuellement 2 et
les faits peuvent vraiment est
considérable n'est ce pas quand on met
ce mur entre une population qui est
affecté une population qui ne l'est pas
on va voir seulement quelques petites
si l'on veut infection qui vont réussir
à traverser le mur là où il ya une
petite ouverture
j'ai vu d'ailleurs un diagramme là
dessus dans je pense était le washington
post aujourd'hui très efficace montrer
sac
jusqu'à quel point ces mesures la
freiner la propagation aussi de division
et ce qu'ils font il faut vraiment
mettre l'enfant sur le fait que c'est un
ensemble de petits gestes de la part de
tout le monde qui va contribuer à
arriver vraiment aplatir cette courbe là
alors les gens peuvent se dire oui mais
moi c'est pas important dans la masse
mais c'est pas vrai faut s'imaginer ça
comme un tableau qui sont vrais ici à
nos tableaux chacun est un petit point
du tableau et c'est la somme de ces
petits points qui va finir par marcher
des gestes comme lesquelles docteur tout
ce qu'on dit aux gens quand on dit aux
gens respecter vos isolement ne sortait
pas soyez en quarantaine ces types donc
tout cet aspect là l'aï risquent d'avoir
tout c'est un ensemble de choses et
c'est ça que les gens vont comprendre
quand on dit la question je dois porter
un masque je dois pas porter un masque
c'est pas une question portait ou pas
porter un masque
c'est l'ensemble des mesures des moyens
qu'on met en place pour réduire tout ça
le fait pas envoyer les enfants à
l'école
ça va certainement aider à diminuer le
nombre d'infections chez les enfants qui
pourraient ensuite les ramener chez
leurs grands parents
donc c'est puis aura pas de masque il
n'y a pas d'histoire de masse mais c'est
un ensemble de deux mesures de choses
qu'on va mettre en place et c'est comme
ça qu'il faut le voir mais prenons un
exemple un milieu de travail où c'est à
aire ouverte comme ici par exemple au
centre de l'information à radio canada
si j'étais plus jeune et si j'avais pu
être au travail de là et que j'avais en
face de moi un mètre ou deux de mois
camarades qui toussait depuis trois
jours et qui ne semblait pas s'en
soucier
est-ce que je dois m'en soucier ou
est-ce que ça ça dit pas vous devriez
vous en souciez mais c'est lui qui
devrait s'en soucier plus parce que s'il
est symptomatique il ne devrait pas être
au travail
il devrait prendre les précautions pour
protéger l'autre ou c'est super parce
que de toute façon on ne veut pas
transmettre ni l'influx en zone ils leur
mort dinars à quelqu'un dont donc une
question de conscientisation et c'est
pour ça qu'on encourage le télétravail
aussi pour qu'ils aient de moins
une de ces situations là où il ya du
rapprochement figé
je pense qu'on peut enseigner se
conscientiser donc effectivement si vous
avez un jeune collègue ou quelqu'un
d'autre qui tous je pense que c'est
important de lui dire de lui recommander
de lui conseiller mais j'ai vu et je
sais qu'il ya dans la ville en ce moment
des interactions agressive donc il ya
des gens qui vont voir quelqu'un tousse
et et qui vont l'interpeller de façon de
façon violente douala sont je pense que
c'est important de faire attention à ça
c'est à dire nous sommes tous
responsables d un réseau nous sommes
responsables de sensibiliser nos
collègues nos amis qui éventuellement ne
suivent pas les mesures donc mais
faisons attention de préserver notre
civilité là dedans de ne pas tomber dans
des modes d'action plus alors que les
spécialistes c'était dans un journal
c'est un besoin qui ont davantage besoin
de civilité et de sens des
responsabilités peut-être même que que
d'autre chose ça devrait être parce que
les gens vont se dénoncer les uns les
autres et faire preuve de gros bon sens
que vous l'avez dit dernièrement qu'on
est venu nous voir dr val d'allier par
les eaux aux employés de radio-canada et
vous avez parlé du gros bon sens dans
toutes ces règles là il ya des moments
où on peut réagir de façon excessive et
l'autre moment où comme le disait madame
bon bain le gros bon sens voudrait que
si je vous donne un exemple on dit on a
mis la barre 70 ans mais si vous avez 68
ans vous avez beaucoup de problèmes de
santé
vous êtes peut-être plus à risque
quelqu'un à 71 et y en a aussi en très
bonne forme
donc il c'est pas quelque chose de
couper au couteau on dit pas plus que
250 personnes il faut que les gens
fassent preuve de gros bon sens si vous
avez 200 personnes vous n'allez pas dire
on est moins de 250 tout va bien aller
alors alors il faut semer dit ça va mal
hein exactement donc il faut aussi du
gros bon sens et ça c'est chaque
individu c'est sa conscience sociale qui
devra y réfléchir et devra prendre des
décisions en conséquence
et quand tout ça sera fini la grippe
saisonnière va revenir et tous après ces
principes là j'comprends bien sûr bon
pour la grippe saisonnière aussi la
mettre à hambach faut absorber ces
comportements là les utiliser entre nous
pour que
on limite la propagation aussi de la
grippe et c'est pour ça que moi je me
dis qu'on peut sortir grandi d'une
épidémie comme celle là en tant que
société parce que toute cette
conscientisation l'envers l'autre envers
son prochain nous rappeler les ennemis
qu'on oublie souvent souvent parfois
dans nos sociétés tous ces petits gestes
là ben je pense qu'on va avoir fait un
grand bout de chemin ensemble leurs
espoirs donc julie de questions par une
question sur l' isolement sur la
quarantaine je vous dirais qu'ils sont
nombreux à nous demander des précisions
là dessus monsieur fortier pouvez vous
s'il vous plaît nous donner une
définition claire de ce que doit
comprendre les mesures d'une quarantaine
par exemple si un seul membre de la
famille est en isolement à la maison que
doivent faire les autres membres de la
famille on en a beaucoup parlé ces
derniers jours mais peut-être de
clarifier la les paramètres en termes
d'un isolement justement à domicile qui
veut se lancer
ça a déjà été expliqué mais je pense que
c'est la situation la plus courante donc
c'est normal que les gens se posent
cette question là puis c'est très
variable selon la sorte de maison la
sorte de logement dans lequel vous
habitez donc l'idée c'est que si la
personne est en isolement parce qu'elle
est positive pour le colis de 19
la personne qui vit avec elle est en
isolement parce qu'elle était en contact
mais si c'est un isolement volontaire
parce que la personne revient de voyage
qu'elle n'est pas symptomatique et puis
tout ça les autres personnes n'ont pas à
être en isolement mais si on est dans la
même maison avec quelqu'un qui est qui
qui est positif
et puis que l'autre personne à temps il
faut essayer de se distancer le plus
possible et puis de nettoyer les
surfaces de seuil et de réserver un
endroit pour la personne atteinte le
plus restreint possible selon où on
habite ça peut être plus ou moins facile
puis l'homme aux faucons on trouve de
l'imagination pour essayer et encore une
fois le gros bon sens pour se dire la
logique lé c'est d'essayer d'éviter des
contacts prolongés d'essayer de bien
nettoyer les surfaces le plus possible
pour éviter le risque de compter le port
du masque le port du masque
encore une fois on dit que le port du
masque pour la personne qui est atteinte
c'est pour la personne qui a des
symptômes parce que c'est elle qui peut
projeter propager là
10 en toussant ou en éternuant donc dans
ces circonstances là c'est une personne
qui est infecté puis l'autre de l'époque
c'est la personne infectée qui doit
partir c'est même s'il ne veut pas
passer un test mais calais les cinq tôt
et qu'elle a des seins de remplacer les
symptômes symptômes parce que c'est ça
qui fait mais c'est le symptôme aussi de
la grippe et il faut toujours se
protéger dit prenons l'exemple la
quarantaine les gens soient pas en
isolement chez eux ils veulent sortir
l'endroit de villes veulent se faire une
nouvelle vie c'est une question qu'on a
reçu également
ils prennent les transports en commun
parce que quand on dit qu on les lave
quoi une fois ou deux par jour
qu'est-ce qu'on faible et encore à
convaincre les autobus mais les légendes
autobus et tous ceux qui disent ne pas
avoir vraiment ce qu'il faut pour se
protéger des gens ni âgées ne prennent
pas l'autobus riverains musulmans
restent chez eux dans leur maison noman
isolement c'était les personnes de 70
ans vous la maison à l'âme chez eux ils
ne prennent pas des transports en commun
avant sort de remarcher
we go magic johnson le tour pour vos
prendre son propre char contre l
épicerie
non non si ça dépend il va falloir un
moment donné qui des choses qui puissent
aussi est pas claire parce que il faut
aider ces gens là justement ne pas aller
à l'épicerie s'ils sont en isolement
donc il faut trouver des moyens et les
compagnies le trouve actuellement
alors il faut aussi que la société
s'organise c'est pour ça que je vous dis
c'est important que tout le monde y met
du sien
alors on trouvera pas toute l'airé
toutes les gérer les résultats à tout le
monde
immédiatement et c'est ça le problème
quand les gens qui sont 1000 et les
entreprises qui sont fermés on ferme les
écoles donc de soi et senna sont pas en
quarantaine est en isolement
il convient télétravail les enseignants
chez eux basse et des enseignants chez
lui font pas télétravail mais ils
peuvent vivre presque normalement les
crues dans l'autobus btan vous n'êtes
pas symptomatique
ouais mais ce qui va aider aussi c'est
que le fait qu'il y aura de moins en
moins de personnes dans l'autobus aussi
c'est que la densité humaine des
transports en commun va diminuer mais ce
qui est juste parce que je peux quelques
confusions et quand les gens sont en
isolement volontaire
premièrement ils le savent parce que ça
leur a été demandé par la santé publique
à la fin de ceux qui rentrent de voyage
de ce
le 12 mars ceux qui rentrent de voyage
qui doivent s' est qu'ils se mettent en
isolement volontaire sont donc ceux qui
sont en isolement volontaire il reste
dans la maison ils peuvent sortir dehors
prendre l'air mais ils ne vont pas dans
les transports en commun ils ne vont pas
dans des regroupements de personnes
ils font pas déporter chez eux l'idée
c'est d'éviter les contacts avec la
crise entre la presse qu'elle soit là
donc quand est ce qu'ils peuvent sortir
la tangente en ce jour après 14 jours et
plus de château le jeu prévu jean pas
besoin d'un autre test
non mais attendez jamais mais l'ambiance
est aussi valide et plus vous parlez
plusieurs catégories on est des gens qui
sont malades ça c'est la première
catégorie
donc ces gens là ont ils vont sortir
quand ils ont plus du tout symptôme est
ce qu'on doit les re tester après la
think et astier actuellement ce qui est
recommandé ses dires testé au moins deux
fois à 72 heures d'intervalle et d'avoir
de test négatif mais après ça il va
falloir voir l'opérationnalisation de
tout ça et est ce que tous les pays font
ça mais ça ce temps je dirais un autre
débat mais ça se fait dans certains pays
ça se fait mais ça c'est le premier le
premier groupe
le deuxième groupe c les gens qui ont
été des contacts de gens malades
les contacts significatif mais qui sont
pas mal alors on leur dit vous avez
rencontré monsieur madame athènes
monsieur madame untel à la maladie vous
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec vous donc on
vous met en isolement en disant vous
allez vous surveiller pendant l'essai
trudeau 14 prochains jours pour vous
assurer que vous n'allez pas développé
des symptômes et si vous développez des
symptômes vous irez chercher de l'aide
et serra et on vous testera je vous
interromps latine parenthèse à mâcon
pour sur deux catégories la personne qui
quitte toujours malade au delà des
quinze jours à 14 jours
alors la personne qui qui est en contact
avec elle pour qu'elle continue plus que
14 jours sans un poids suffisant
ces 14 jours à partir du moment où la
personne qui avec vous qui était malade
est guéri oui mais qu'il ya un test qui
montre qu'elle n'est plus à faire dans
le ses 14 plus 14 il est regardé mon
ambition c'est ça la complexité c'est
pas ça dépend si vous êtes un exemple le
conjoint ou la conjointe de quelqu'un de
malade
là ça peut durer plus longtemps mais si
vous avez eu un contact disons
épisodiques avec quelqu'un qui lui a été
malade dont vous êtes un enseignant vous
avez un autre enseignant qui a été
malade vous allez plus avoir de contact
avec cette personne là
à la suite donc là encore il ya d'autres
scénarios qui font envisager alors fait
d'efforts importants et éclairant on va
les repose-mains là monsieur on revient
tout de suite après puis on va faire le
point sur la situation qui a beaucoup
évolué va évoluer dans les dernières
heures au canada alors nous ferons un
tour avec nos journalistes bassin
mauvais geneviève normes entre les
peuples ans et charlotte du moulin il
faudra le ministre joint du tout dans le
calcul est également tout de suite reste
habité je suis une préoccupation
[Musique]
la vos questions avec nos invités à tout
de suite
[Musique]
la situation évolue très rapidement
partout au pays on recense actuellement
317,4 de kobe de 10,9 au canada dont 73
seulement en colombie britannique
c'est le chiffre a été revu à 16 heures
peut-être que ça a déjà augmenté parce
que depuis le début de l'émission les
cas au québec ont aussi augmenté on va
s'y de voulu confirmer avant la fin de
cette émission
la seule personne décédée coronavirus du
canada et être résident d'un centre de
soins de longue durée de 9 ans couvreur
je vois maintenant brian cole we
directeur médical du centre des maladies
infectieuses de vancouver je crois que
je vous rejoins weasley mais la station
de ski est fermé donc il ya des mesures
quand même qui sont prises en colombie
britannique
quelle est la situation chez vous il ya
beaucoup d'inquiétudes au québec qui est
beaucoup de mesures de mesures
importantes qui ont été annoncés
aujourd'hui quel est votre point de vue
de la situation réelle chez vous en ce
moment ça fait plaisir d'être avec vous
ce soir à comme vous le redire 73 cas
qui ont été confirmés en colombie
britannique ont une réponse de santé
publique et à la fois ciblée et robuste
qui doit viser à minimiser le nombre de
nouveaux cas qui vont au diagnostic et
au cours de la prochaine semaine
et quel est votre réalité avoue comme
médecin du travail auprès des patients
est ce que et quelle est la situation du
système de santé quel est le quotidien
chez vous les temps donné les pressions
qui s'exercent sur le système et sur le
personnel
ce gros impact sur tout le système de
santé en général pour des spécialistes
en technologies tellement même et pour
pour mot centre on est interpellé sur
une base quotidienne est presque à
chaque heure sur ce sujet-là et des
mesures de santé publique qui s'imposent
qu'on doit toujours se rappeler se laver
les mains souvent toussé éternué
dansokho du dans un mouchoir
si on est malade vraiment rester à la
maison et de signaler des contacts
possibles avec une nouveau création
parle de tous les clubs qui ont eu lieu
en colombie britannique
à venir jusqu'à maintenant il ya eu très
peu de coke et des transmissions à
l'intérieur des provinces des explosions
sur la rive nord
c'est à dire des gens qui revenaient de
d'étrangers et nous retrace une virus
dans des centres de longue durée
donc on demeure vigilant
pour essayer d'identifier les éclosions
le plus rapidement possible de répondre
aux questions dans le quotidien la façon
la plus folle sans vouloir qu'annick et
les gens mais les responsabiliser est-ce
qu'on a pris toutes les mesures qu'il
fallait prendre à ce jour en s'inspirant
notamment de ce qui se fait ici au
québec ou ailleurs parce qu'il faut
vraiment faire la part des choses on
essaie de minimiser le nombre de
nouveaux corps qui sont répandues à
travers la province au diagnostic et à
mesure qu'on voyait dans 6 des nouveaux
kof révisé sur une base quotidienne
les mesures vont changer dans les
centres de ski fermer les cours en ligne
versus en personne des nouvelles
consignes sur les rassemblements de
certain nombre de personnes vivent ici
il ya à peine une heure 250 personnes
maximum 150 personnes cherchent n'est
que l'autre a banni de la santé publique
simple mauritanie va reprendre ses
bonnes consignes en ligne de fond en
faisant des annonces qui sont faites sur
une base quotidienne donc à 10 heures du
matin
que pensez vous des mesures comme celles
annoncées au québec est fière et
d'autres importantes aujourd'hui de
mettre en isolement toutes les personnes
âgées de plus de 70 ans
parce que c'est les personnes qui sont à
plus haut risque d'avoir des
conséquences sérieuses de l'infection et
à mesure qu'on essaie de développer les
programmes de santé publique qui vont
très applicable à toute la population
c'est une mesure qui est justifiable et
qui doit être reconsidéré sur une base
quotidienne compte tenu des faits qui
vont qui vont se développer des mesures
aussi efficace je pense logiquement de
rassurer en interne de façon sécuritaire
se sait des choses de qui vont réduire
votre avis sur les maladies de façon
qu'ils étaient prouvées alors qu'on
avait l'année qu'est ce qu'on demande en
terminant ce qu'on demande est ce que ta
voix en fasse plus je pense que c'est au
nom de santé en ontario et ailleurs des
décisions sont prises sur une base
provinciale 60 ans que tu ne montes ce
concept
et puis les demandes de 3 à la ta voix
votre confiance et je pense au cours de
la prochaine semaine ça va être surtout
de
du de l'appui la concertation du
financement merci infiniment
d'attaquants noyau plaisir merci à vous
la branchez vous julie maistre avait des
questions
oui on y va avec des questions vraiment
sur les tests de dépistage en soit les
gens qui se posent toutes sortes de
questions sur que ce soit comment ces
tests déroulent ou encore sur leur
efficacité la première va dans ce sens
et marie hélène morin qui nous demande
serait ce possible de savoir de
connaître le taux d'efficacité du test
de dépistage
et elle ajoute viatique beaucoup de faux
positifs ou de faux négatifs qui chance
je pourrais rapidement vous répondre
alors d'abord il n'ya pas beaucoup des
faux positifs non parce que c'est
vraiment très très 106 pour la technique
là on veut vraiment aller chercher de
virus des faux négatifs ça va dépendre
beaucoup du type de prélèvement qu'on va
faire on vous a dit la façon dont on
dépiste ça on fait des échos villon au
niveau de la gorge et puis au niveau du
nasopharynx et on met ça dans un milieu
transport et après ça on fait une
technique de biologie moléculaire votre
question oui certainement pour la vigne
cette fois de kenge phase qui nous
demandent pourquoi devons-nous effectuer
les tests de dépistage du côté de
winnipeg au laboratoire national de
microbiologie
elle ajoute ce test doit certainement
exister dans les pays fortement touchés
comme en asie ou en europe y aura-t-il
moyens justement d'effectuer les tests à
plus courte distance mais c'est vraiment
les autres provinces à ce serait plus
effectivement présentement on est en
train de décentraliser les tests à
travers le pays
au début c'est laboratoire national de
microbiologie qu développer le test en
fait le lspq le développer avant même l
os et décentralisé et maintenant ça va
être décentralisé encore davantage au
cours des prochaines semaines
on voit que ça progresse donc de 100
euros il a également faut suivre un
ensemble de l'évolution dans tout ça
jacques gervais maintenant qu'ils
demandent est ce exact de penser que les
taux de mortalité avancent actuellement
sont possiblement surestimées car dit il
les données utilisées pour les calculs
tiendrait possiblement compte seulement
des cas les plus sévères est ce que
c'est vrai ou c'est un ami a en fait ce
qui est vrai c'est qu'on ne connaît pas
vraiment précisément le taux de létalité
de cette infection là parce qu'on ne
connaît pas le dénominateur donc de
combien de personnes ont été exposées au
virus qui aurait peut-être fait une
maladie possédait rapeau symptomatique
puis pour établir un bon taux
de létalité il faut vraiment avoir un
bon dénominateur on va pouvoir le voir
juste à la fin quand on va faire les
cédrid les études sérologique dont
madame r parlé plus tôt
donc maintenant c'est pour ça que young
rend une grande variation dans l'estimé
entre points 5 % et 3.5 pourcent ne peut
être précisé que le taux est calculé sur
le nombre de personnes qui ont été
testées donc que ce soit sévère ou
modérée donc ça inclut les 85% qui se
sont rétablis parfaitement de la maladie
oui dont on ne parle pas assez peut-être
c'est une des questions qui reviennent
beaucoup anne marie justement pourquoi
ne parle t'on pas plus que ça de ces
gens de guérir qui ont vaincu la maladie
la prochaine question anonymes qui nous
vient d'un médecin de famille en région
c'est ainsi qu'il se présentait ils se
demandent si leur m d hiver cet
antiviral prometteur pourrait être
utilisé pour soigner lakovic 19 j'ai vu
quelques articles a su dans les derniers
jours qu en est il
oui on peut l'utiliser d'ailleurs on
peut la voir par accès spécial au canada
et la compagnie gilead et nous l'envoyer
donc est ce qu'il ya des médicaments
dont vous auriez besoin qui sont pas
acceptés mais que vous pouvez avoir des
règles spéciales
l'ofgem des civils est en étude
présentement pour évaluer son efficacité
donc ce n'est pas la panacée puis le
médicament miracle donc on n'est pas
certain qu'une grande grande efficacité
mais à première vue il a été utilisé
puis a eu des résultats possibles dans
certains cas aux états unis en a entre
autres mets donc il est en train d'être
étudiées dans des essais cliniques
présentement en chine et aux états unis
peut-être peut-être juste rajouter sur
permettait parce que j'étais a donc à la
conférence téléphonique hebdomadaire des
conseils scientifiques en chef des douze
payer que j'ai mentionnés donc on nous a
confirmé que sur les 201 études
cliniques qui est se dérouler en chine
tous les résultats à jour sont négatifs
nous espérons que ça veut dire qu'il
n'ya pas et n'ont pas trouvé un
médicament qui fonctionnait même pas
celui là
ben je trouve ça vraiment là il est
testé on n'a pas vraiment d'études
publiées mais c'est à peu près la seule
chose qu'on a actuellement
on a essayé aussi d'autres médicaments
on essaie des vieux médicaments qu'on
utilisait pour le vih comme le cas les
trains on a essayé de la chloroquine il
ya beaucoup de médicaments qu'on a
essayé mais il n'y a pas d'étude bien
fait qui démontre que a est vraiment
efficace par rapport à b il ya beaucoup
de gens qui manque c'est ce qu'ils ont
été par exemple vaccinés contre la
pneumonie à pneumocoque novak sait ce
que ça ça peut les rendre moins
vulnérables d'avoir des complications se
contractent la maladie
ça va les protéger contre le pneumocoque
le pneumocoque créé une pneumonie qui
peut compliquer une pneumonie virale
comme c'est souvent le cas dans
l'influenza
par contre quand on regarde le tableau
clinique des gens qui sont atteints de
lakovic 19 même la maladie sévère il ya
beaucoup moins de surinfection
bactérienne dans ces colloques hommes
comparativement ce qu'on voit avec l'
influence mais c'est très bien de se
faire vacciner contre le pneumocoque 6
est indiqué pour vous parce que c'est
sûr que ça va vous aider à vous protéger
dans l'ensemble contre contre des
surinfections bactériennes
on sait qu'il ya des coronavirus qui
circulent dans la société mais plusieurs
et qui sont passablement bénin mais dr
weiss et ce qu'ils peuvent nous
immuniser d'une certaine façon contre
ces deux virus qui circule actuellement
c'est une excellente question parce que
vous savez il ya quelques années du à
l'époque du strass il y avait une
éclosion dalle coronavirus benalla
quiros et 43 dans un centre je pense de
soins prolongés en colombie-britannique
et il avait testé les gens mais pour le
strass parce qu'à cette époque là c'est
l'époque du strass et il pensait que
c'était le strass mais finalement ça
l'était pas alors on voit que il peut y
avoir une certaine homologie en ces
virus là est ce que ça peut nous
protéger la question est un point
d'interrogation c'est ni oui ni non
je peux que si vous ayez déjà des
anticorps récents contre certains
coronavirus il pourrait y avoir
peut-être une protection partielle mais
cet inconnu pour l'instant
on peut l'imaginer théoriquement mais je
peux pas vous dire ni oui ni non là
dessus quand on fera les tests de
sérologie donc de déterminer sur les
anticorps est ce qu'on va pouvoir faire
la différence si c'est compliqué ayant
potentiellement mais il faut utiliser
une technique de nous qu'on appelle de
neutralisation qui est compliqué à
utiliser pour faire ce genre de choses
là on n'est pas encore très bon pour
faire des tests de sérologie spécifiques
à une espèce de corona je vous dirai pas
quelque chose qu'on connaît ou qu'on a
fait parce qu'on n'en avait pas le
besoin c'est pas comme pour le vih ou il
fallait avoir des tests de dépistage des
choses comme ça une question gênante
qu'elles sont sur les personnes les plus
vulnérables hadmar et on nous demande
jean denis philly à trois faits qui nous
demandent est ce vrai que les personnes
diabétiques en fait serait plus à risque
de contracter la maladie et l'on ne
parle pas nécessairement d'avoir des
complications c'est il contracte lakovic
19 mai être plus à risque de la
contracter en soi est ce que c'est le
cas à ce jour il n'y a pas de données
qui me disent que les gens qui ont ces
maladies la de base sont plus à risque
de l'attraper
c'est surtout les données sont très
fortes dans le sens de dire que ceux qui
ont des maladies comme ça risque de
faire plus de complications d'avoir une
forme plus sévère de la maladie
peut-être qu'avec le recul on va pouvoir
mieux comprendre ça mais mais là je
pense pas que sont plus à risque de
l'attraper
merci une autre question oui marie
hélène amstrong qui est éducatrice donc
d'une garderie en milieu familial et qui
nous demandent justement à savoir si le
fait d'accueillir des enfants issus en
fait du milieu de la santé oms dont les
parents
travaille dans le milieu de la santé et
donc poursuivre leur activité
professionnelle
l'âme est elle plus à risque justement
de contracter la maladie qui veut
répondre moi je vous dirais que n'ont
pas forcément je veux dire dans le
milieu de la santé en général je ne dis
pas qu'il ya eu des cas de transmission
il est fort possible qu'il va y en avoir
mais les gens sont protégés en mai des
mesures de protection il n'y a pas
quelque chose d'absolu mais j'ai pas on
peut pas ne peut pas faire ce genre
d'assertion mais là dessus ça m'amène
cette question mais espère une réaction
de ce qui a été dit sur québec sébastien
a bien mentionné a bien rapporté les
inquiétudes du gouvernement puis les
scénarios probables de cas et tout ça et
de l'impact que ça pourra voir on pose
la question sur quand même sur le
système de santé d'où vient-il il y en a
peut-être je pense qu'il ya alors
peut-être pas un risque énorme
mais un petit risque oui sans doute de
la même façon que nous nous travailleurs
de la santé nous devons assumer et je
pense que c'est notre responsabilité
un risque accru parce que nous
travaillerons alors donc la question
c'est nous ne pouvons pas continuer à
faire fonctionner notre système de santé
si un certain nombre de gens les
travailleurs de la santé ceux qui les
soutiennent aussi ceux qui gardent leurs
enfants n'assume pas un certain risque
donc c'est le fait de se dire ça fait
partie de nos solidarités ce collectif
alors que ce risque ne soit pas
important c'est notre responsabilité
d'essayer de prendre soin de tout le
monde mais qu'il y ait un certain risque
oui plus élevés pour certaines personnes
oui je pense que ça fait partie de ce
que sait à quoi nous devons faire parler
sur ce qui a été décidé
et affirmer à québec aujourd'hui le
scénario est très inquiétant quand il
est dans la durée un char vous arriviez
montrer la cour tout à l'heure ça
pourrait durer des mois par les deux
jusqu'en septembre m'a écouté c'est sûr
mais je pense que les gens se préparent
pour le pire scénario en espérant si
vous voulez la meilleure sortie mais
c'est mieux de faire ça que depuis se
préparer pour un scénario rose et
d'avoir un gros problème comme on a pu
voir en italie ou ailleurs dans c'est
tout à fait normal que les mesures qui
ont été prises
essai de comptabiliser ce qui va être le
plus difficile cela il faut regarder ça
comme une espèce de guerre où l'objectif
est de gagner la guerre il se peut qu'on
perd des batailles je ne savais pas dire
que c'est un recul ça veut pas dire que
le gouvernement a mal fait son travail
ça veut dire que tous les efforts ont
été émis mais on n'aura pas tout parfait
l'objectif c'est par contre d'arriver à
gagnant de cette histoire chose madame
sophie chabot répondu que cela reste
très peu tard mais le modèle de
communication choisi à québec est assez
rassurant on nous tient au courant même
si on donne l'heure juste en tout cas et
ça c'est important et votre autre les
cactus sont les les communautés
vulnérables et plus propre et moins
nantis les étudiants les gens qui sont
même pas me réfugier des gens qui sont
très nombreux dans un tout petit
appartement qui parle pas nécessairement
dans l'offre en fait il ya une longue
liste de voeux la création alors je
pense que maintenant nous avons pris des
décisions comme société il faut les
traduire en communication pour chaque
groupe et pour chaque groupe d'agents
pour les aînés isolés mais aussi pour
les communautés culturelles pour les
gens qui vivent dans la grande pauvreté
de façon comme lors des canicules
finalement pour que puis nous puissions
rejoindre et protéger tous ces gens là
surtout ceux qui sont le plus à risque
bon c'est que distants station sociale
et les allemands sont des méthodes très
efficace m'a beaucoup parlé du lavage
des mains avec le savons il loue je veux
juste revenir là dessus parce que j'ai
lu un article dernièrement qui est
absolument fascinant qui démontrait
pourquoi au niveau moléculaire et
chimique l'eau et le savon détruisent
les vies
ce l'assassinât répondent par un virus
qu'une enveloppe qui est faite de
lipides et puis donc les savons en
général ce sont des molécules qui vont
par éclater l'enveloppent du virus et
donc mon le détruire en plus de bien
faire glisser toutes les peaux mortes
qu'on a sur les mecs sont des trappes à
bactéries et virus en général alors le
bon vieux savon qui sans qui existe
depuis des années des siècles encore une
des meilleures méthodes un mot de la fin
en quelques secondes chacun qu'est-ce
que vous que l'on retient de notre
conversation de ce soir ben moi je
dirais que nous faisons face à une
situation qui est sérieuse qu'on doit la
prendre au sérieux et que la science
nous aident et va continuer à nous aider
et grâce à découverte aussi mince d'un
projet de solidarité ou tous ensemble on
arrivera à 20khz finalement ce virus une
fois qu'on a pris des grandes mesures le
foulée opérationnaliser pour être sûr de
pas laisser personne derrière nous les
personnes âgées et vulnérables si on
veut tenir le coup il faut travailler à
notre bien-être au bien être de tous
merci beaucoup merci charles lui aussi
retrouvé rssi julie est mon prochain
rendez vous on se lève quand même
monsieur la fin de cette émission
spéciale avec une carte du canada avec
le nombre total de cas nous sommes
maintenant à 341 cas à surveiller
l'évolution sur nos zones merci à vous
d'avoir été au rendez vous à la
prochaine
au revoir